Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Jeden zweiten Monat reitet der Chaos Computer Club hier ein, also er selbst höchstpersönlich oder Leute, die damit zu tun haben und erklärt etwas zu Themen, die irgendwie mit diesem seltsamen Internet zu tun haben und den neuartigen Rundfunk- und Gefangskeräten, die sie darin befinden. Und es wird alles nicht mehr weggehen. Und es gibt Probleme und gute Dinge. Und all das wird hier berichtet im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Es ist wieder so weit. Das Jahr ist beinahe rum. Und zu Gast sind heute vom Chaos Computer Club der Peter. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Der Dani Mo. Hallo und guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
Und der Mutags.
Hallo und guten Abend. Hallo.
Und es soll jetzt heute um ein ist. Da freue ich mich immer besonders drauf, wenn es diese Themen gibt. Es gibt ja so Sachen, die immer und überall schon so anklingen. Und alle sagen, ja, das wird jetzt das neue Ding. Und keiner weiß aber so richtig genau, wie das funktioniert.
Aber wir sollen es auch alle kaufen.
Und es ist aber auch ganz gefährlich. Und wovon rede ich eigentlich? Vom Internet of Things. Das Beispiel, was dafür verwendet wird seit Jahren und was es immer noch nicht gibt, ist, der Kühlschrank bestellt die Milch, wenn sie alle ist. Das wird dann immer wieder angekündigt. Das ist das große Traumding, was da mal passieren soll. Jedes Jahr zu IFA wird dann auch gesagt, ja, das wird jetzt ganz toll, irgendwie Dinge gehen online. Bei Fernsehern wird uns das auch schon seit Jahren zu verkaufen versucht, dass die jetzt auch ganz toll irgendwie Dinge können. Und da gibt es jede Menge zu sagen. Und deswegen sind wir heute hier. Der Anlass, warum wir heute hier genau sind, also ganz konkret ist aber noch etwas anderes, nämlich ein sogenannter IT-Gipfel. Da wurde nämlich über das Internet of Things gesprochen, unter anderem. Und der Montags war da. Genau, und bevor wir also über das Internet of Things reden, würde ich gerne auch erst mal wissen, weil das ist ja auch ganz interessant als, ich sag mal, normalsterblicher. Diesen IT-Gipfel, die gibt es einmal im Jahr. Das ist irgendwie von der Regierung ein so ein Ding, wo halt Politik und Wirtschaft aufeinandertreffen und Dinge besprechen und dann werden immer ganz tolle O-Töne gegeben. Von wegen das Internet ist die Zukunft und so. Aber was genau ist dieser IT-Gipfel eigentlich?
Na der IT-Gipfel ist der Versuch von der Politik zu erfahren, und zwar von der Wirtschaft, was das so mit dem Internet ist und wie man damit in Zukunft umgehen möchte. Also eigentlich möchte die Politik steuern, in welche Richtung wir da gehen und möchte, dass wir als Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland weiterhin erfolgreich sind. Und dieses Jahr war ganz großes Thema, dass man den Mittelstand mit Start-ups verbinden möchte. Das heißt, es gab dann da so eine Plattform Industrie 4.0.
Okay, warte mal, ich muss langsam machen. Also die gute Nachricht ist schon mal, der Staat glaubt, man kann das Internetloch zu anderen Dingen benutzen als zur Überwachung. Das ist jetzt schon angekommen.
Ja, das ist durchaus angekommen, aber der Fokus da ist schon sehr, sehr stark auf der Wirtschaft. Also wie schaffen wir das, dass wir mit unserem Mittelstand weiterhin erfolgreich bleiben und auch weiterhin Marktführer oder führende Wirtschaftsnationen werden auch im Bereich Internet, was ja jetzt irgendwie ganz neu ist plötzlich.
Mit anderen Worten irgendwie das Silicon Valley links überholen?
Ja, sowas in der Art. Also sie gucken halt alle dahin und haben aber auch langsam verstanden, dass man sich einfach kopieren kann, weil das hier nicht funktioniert. Das ist auch schon mal eine ganz gute Erkenntnis. Und ansonsten ist es halt eine, ja doch vom Gefühl her, sehr starke Wirtschaftsförderaktion und der IT-Gipfel ist ja nur das Sichtbare, also das, was man hinterher sieht. Der IT-Gipfel ist einmal im Jahr, wo die ganzen Arbeitsgruppen, die es da so das Jahr über verteilt gibt, präsentieren, was sie das Jahr über erarbeitet haben.
Also wie genau kommt man dahin? Also du warst ja da.
Wieso bist du auf dem IT-Gipfel?
Da sind ja nur Leute, die Millionen schwer sind.
Das hängt damit zusammen, dass nächstes Jahr der IT-Gipfel einen starken Schwerpunkt auf Bildungspolitik oder auf Bildung haben wird. Wie ändert das Internet, das wie gesagt jetzt auch ganz neu bei der Bildung ankommt. Denn Bildung, Ausbildung, Weiterbildung, das fängt halt irgendwie in der Schule an. Da geht aber auch über berufliche Qualifizierung. Wie schafft man es, dass Leute da jetzt nicht den Anschluss verlieren? Weil plötzlich ist ja IT überall da und jeder muss auch mit Rechnern umgehen können. Der gesamte Arbeitsmarkt wird ja von IT durchdrungen und da muss schon dringend was passieren. Also wenn man sich so anguckt, dass Leute halt nicht wissen, dass sie Dinge automatisieren können am Rechner und immer noch so Tage und Wochen lang manuell irgendwelche Daten in Listen eintragen und berechnen oder so. Da wäre das schon irgendwie ganz spannend, wenn Leute eine Möglichkeit hätten zu lernen, wie man sich das Leben da einfacher machen kann, damit auch IT da praktisch ankommt. Und nächstes Jahr, wie gesagt, wird ein großer Schwerpunkt auch für Bildung sein. Das Bildungsministerium kam also irgendwann dann auf meine Chefin zu. Ich arbeite an der Uni und hat gefragt, ob sie da nicht irgendwie ihre Qualifikation einbringen möchte, weil eben auch von der scientific community da irgendwie Input abgefragt wird.
Okay, wie muss man sich dann also diesen IT-Gipfel dann vorstellen? Sitzen dann irgendwie die Bundeskanzlerin mit dem Chef von SAP auf einer Bühne, dann sagt der Chef, wir brauchen mehr Internet und die Kanzlerin macht, aha ja, das hört sich gut an oder was genau ist jetzt da?
Ja, das läuft dann so ab, es gibt zwei Tage, am ersten Tag ist halt die Politik noch nicht so anwesend, da gibt es aber dann so Panel-Diskussionen. Die Diskussionen sind im Prinzip auch nur Darstellen von Ergebnissen, die im letzten Jahr eben erarbeitet wurden. Das heißt, da ist dann irgendwie der Chef von irgendeinem Startup und da ist dann der Bahnchef da und dann ist da die Kanzlerin und dann wird darüber diskutiert, was denn die Bahn zum Beispiel alles macht, um Startups zu fördern oder ein Startup erzählt, was so seine Probleme sind. Das ist aber wie gesagt alles so Wissenstransportation, wissenstransportierend von dem, was das ja über passiert ist und die eigentliche Arbeit passiert in Arbeitsgruppen und in einer von diesen Arbeitsgruppen, in einer von diesen Plattformen, so nennen die das, bin ich dann drin, vertrete als so genannter Schärper meine Chefin. Das heißt, ich darf dann da so die Arbeit machen und die eigentlichen Plattformmitglieder, so heißt das tatsächlich offiziell, kommen dann auch so zwei, drei Mal im Jahr zusammen zu einer großen Sitzung mit der Ministerin, die dann dafür zuständig ist und besprechen dann eben, wie man da so weiter vorgeht und was so die Ergebnisse aus den Unterarbeitsgruppen jeweils waren.
Also man kann sich im Begriff schon vorstellen, das ist so eine Art glorifiziertes Seminar, Blogseminar aus der Uni.
Na, aber schon so, also dass die Arbeitsgruppen tatsächlich versuchen, da auch tatsächlich, also zumindest in denen, in denen ich war, war es doch sehr unterschiedlich. Es gab eine Arbeitsgruppe, die sehr wirtschaftsdominiert ist, wo es natürlich dann darum geht, was die in der Weiterbildung ihrer Mitarbeiter machen und wo die sich gesellschaftlich engagieren, weil sie natürlich einen Return of Investment haben wollen, dafür, dass sie da in diesen Arbeitsgruppen sind. Das heißt, so eine Firma wie die Telekom oder SAP oder Microsoft, die dann da am Tisch sitzen, wollen natürlich auch, dass die Politik sieht, was sie an Engagement bringen in Schulen zum Beispiel, um da irgendwie jetzt nicht irgendwie SAP Werbung zu machen. Die machen wohl tatsächlich für Schüler und Schülerinnen da Kurse und Kram.
Warte mal, macht der Chaos Computer Club aber auch der Chaos macht Tule? Der war aber nicht auf dem IT-Gipfel.
Genau, das ist auch ein riesengroßer Kritikpunkt an diesem ganzen IT-Gipfelprozess, weil das eine sehr geschlossene Veranstaltung ist, wo halt wirklich im Wesentlichen Wirtschaft da ist oder auf Einlagen der Politik. Letztes Jahr wurde schon versprochen, dass der sich öffnen würde und dass da mehr Beteiligung ist. Das Problem ist, dass man davon gesehen hat dieses Jahr eine Panel-Diskussion mit Frank Rieger, der eben dann mit Demesier da vorne saß, wo Demesier ihn dann um diese berühmte Notfallnummer vom CCC gefragt hat bei Computerproblemen im Ministerium.
Was, was, was? Ich hab jetzt nur am Rande gelesen.
Naja, also es gab dann irgendwie so die Anfrage, naja, wir müssen ja jetzt alle zusammenhalten bei dem Terrorismus und dem ganzen Internetkram und so, und ob da nicht die Expertise des CCC auch abgefragt werden könne. Also das war dann so, ich glaube, das war nicht so ganz ernst gemeint, ehrlich gesagt.
Wer weiß. So, es ging aber auf diesem IT-Gipfel um das Internet of Things und wir müssen gleich nochmal genauer drüber sprechen, weil ja die Kanzlerin Gerüchte haben sollte, wie so, ja, also das mit dem Datenschutz, also da muss man, das muss man aber auch nicht so ernst nehmen, weil wir brauchen halt die Datenwahlwirtschaft. Es war noch schlimmer. Es war noch schlimmer, ok, dazu kommen wir gleich. Erstmal möchte ich von euch nämlich wissen, und ich hätte jetzt gerne, na warte mal, ihr seid drei Leute, es gibt wahrscheinlich drei verschiedene Definitionen, was ist denn eigentlich das Internet of Things ganz genau? Also wie gesagt, man hört immer, der Kühlschrank, der mir die Milch kauft. Was ist das Internet of Things, Peter? Halt! Der Peter hat gerade nichts gesagt, weil er noch die Kamera eingestellt hat. Man kann nämlich diese Sendung nicht nur hören, sondern auch sehen, und zwar auf streaming.media.ccc.de, richtig?
Richtig.
Sehr gut. So, Peter, und was ist das Internet of Things?
Naja, es ist wie Cloud natürlich ein sehr schwammiger Begriff, aber ich würde es immer so definieren, es geht darum, dass sich Maschinen miteinander unterhalten, ohne dass man selber dazwischen ist. Also sonst ist es ja immer, man selber redet über den Computer mit Facebook oder sowas, und da ist es halt, der Kühlschrank redet mit dem Server vom Supermarkt oder das Fitbit an deinem Arm redet vielleicht mit dem Anbieter der Fitnessplattform dahinter. Also eine Kommunikation, mit der du eigentlich nichts zu tun hast, so richtig, und für gewöhnlich, das ist auch wieder was schwammig, sind IOT-Device für gewöhnlich Geräte, die Single Purpose sind. Also sowas wie so ein Fitbit, da kannst du keinen Film drauf gucken, da kannst du auch nicht irgendwie eine App Installe in Angry Birds spielen, sondern es ist einfach ein Ding, was nur eine Sache kann, meistens auch keine oder vielleicht nur einen Knopf, vielleicht ein rudimentäres Display oder gar keins. Ein simpelstes Beispiel wäre vielleicht so ein Temperatursensor oder sowas.
Der dann aus welchen Gründen auch immer im Internet ist und dort mit einem anderen Rechner redet.
Genau, wenn der in so einem...
Der irgendwo anders steht und nicht bei mir.
Naja, der kann auch bei dir stehen. Also die Devices können auch ja untereinander mit sich reden. Also die können auch beide in deinem Wohnzimmer sein. Da muss nicht unbedingt richtig viel Internet dazwischen sein. Aber es ist halt meistens damit Spaß macht, damit du eine App am Telefon hast, mit der du dann irgendwie mit dem Ding interagieren kannst, weil das Ding selber hat ja meistens keine Knöpfe.
Okay, also du sagst, ein Internet, ein Thing-Internet, nee, ein Thing auf Internet ist etwas, was kein Computer ist, aber im Internet hängt.
Nein, ein Computer ist streng genommen schon, aber kein Laptop, kein Desktop-PC, kein Smartphone.
Danimo, was ist das Internet of Things?
Peter hat im Prinzip schon die...
Warst du Entschuldigung?...
die Definition geliefert, die man von Enzyklopädie erwarten würde. Das Einzige, was ich vielleicht nochmal anmerken möchte, ist, hat es bei Peter gerade ganz kurz durchgeklungen. Also, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist dieses Internet of Things nicht zwingend, also Internet im Sinne von das heutige Internet, das ist halt die Plattform, aber das Internet in dem Internet of Things bezieht sich halt auch, wenn ich das so richtig verstanden habe, darauf, dass die einfach miteinander reden können und nicht so sehr auf die heutige Technologie Internet.
Na ja, das Internet ist ja ein Network of Networks.
Ja, aber wird es jetzt philosophisch?
Internetworks, nein, das Internet ist definiert als Netzwerk von miteinander verbundenen Netzwerken. Also ein super Netzwerk von Netzwerken, von daher ist das schon da drin.
Ja, also ich meine, die würde es wahrscheinlich in den meisten Definitionen, die Online-Anbindung irgendwie mit drin haben, weil sonst ist es halt einfach nur so Sensor-Netzwerk zu Hause. Und damit es Internet ist und nicht nur net, also Zwischennetzen musste halt noch mal irgendwie ein Gateway dazwischen. Aber im Prinzip ist es für die reine Funktionalität fast egal.
Okay, also dann halt, fest ist Internet oder hast du jetzt noch?
Na ja, Internet ist, wenn die Cloud aus dem Toaster kommt.
Aha, okay, so jetzt wissen wir also, es geht um Dinge, die irgendwie im Internet sind. Da frage ich mich als nächstes natürlich, warum? Was sind denn da so Anwendungsbeispiele?
Sehr schön, na ja, also was sind Anwendungsbeispiele? Peter hatte gerade ein paar genannt. Ein anderes, was es gibt, Amazon hatte vor kurzem etwas vorgestellt, das sich Dash nennt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei allen angekommen ist.
Nein, erklär mal bitte.
Das sind, also stell dir vor, du stehst vor deiner Spülmaschine und stellst fest, dass deine Spülmaschinentaps leer sind. Was würdest du normalerweise machen? Woher weißt du das? Naja, weil du vielleicht gerade einen Spül einsetzen wolltest.
Okay, also ja, ich würde normalerweise einen auf meinem Smartphone an den Alltag machen.
Idealerweise möchtest du natürlich, dass die Spülmaschine das irgendwie selber merkt. Aber in dem Fall bist du derjenige, musst den Spülvorgang ja eh erstmal in Gang setzen und einräumen. Also so weit sind wir ja noch nicht, dass das alles automatisch geht. Und da gibt es dann halt so Buttons, die du an deine Spülmaschine kleben kannst, da drauf drückst und dann weiß irgendwie Amazon, oh bei dem ist es leer, dann schicke ich doch mal irgendwie gerade per Express neue, damit er wieder spülen kann.
Und dieser Button ist halt so ein kleines Gerät mit Batterie drin und W-Line-Ship, dass man irgendwo hin kleben kann und genau ein Knopf hat. Bestelle Spielmaschinen-Taps.
Das heißt, der Knopf wird vorher irgendwie programmiert, der kommt mit schöner Beschriftung und ist glaube ich voreingestellt.
Ja, das kann man selber nicht ändern. Gibt es dann irgendwie eine Handvoll von Produkten.
Okay.
Also letztendlich die Fortführung von ihrem Abo-Modell, was sie da haben. Du kannst ja auch Klopapier im Abo kaufen und jetzt musst du halt nicht mehr, wenn du dann mal drei Wochen nicht zu Hause bestapelt sich das Zeug, sondern du drückst halt den Knopf, wenn es leer ist und dann kommt es nach.
Na gut, hört sich doch spannend an. Gibt es da was dran auszusetzen?
Na ja, wie bei den meisten Technologien, ist es halt immer eine Frage der Implementierung. Also rein theoretisch kann man sowas natürlich relativ datensparsam und auch sicher implementieren.
Na ja, also ich rede jetzt erst mal nur von diesem Knopf.
Den, also ich habe ihn mir noch nicht eingeguckt, weil es ihn in Deutschland noch nicht gibt. Da da ihr Payment dranhängt, denke ich mal, dass sie zumindest auf die Sicherheit geachtet haben. Wie datensparsam das Ganze, dann ist es halt wieder eine andere Frage. In dem Moment, wo ich zum Beispiel sehr genau weiß, wann du 60 Spültaps verbraucht hast, kann ich schon wieder grob approximieren, wie oft du spülst. Daraus kann ich vielleicht wieder andere Dinge ableiten. Also je genauer und zeithoch aufgelöster ich Daten über dich habe, desto mehr kann ich halt auch über dich sagen.
Und da kommen wir zu dem Punkt, wo ihr, liebe Hörer, heute auch mitmachen könnt. Denn wir würden gerne von euch wissen, wie ihr das seht, weil wir werden heute viel über Dinge reden, die man sich zu Hause installieren kann und die vielleicht ganz cool sind und das Leben leichter machen oder die man auch am Körper trägt, aber die halt irgendwie mit dem Internet verbunden sind und dann auch Daten übermitteln. Deswegen zwei Fragen an euch. Die erste, benutzt ihr schon irgendwas, was man über als Internet of Things bezeichnen könnte? Also Fitbit, also diese Fitnessarmen, da wurde ja auch schon genannt, oder würdet ihr euch so einen Knopf installieren oder habt ihr schon irgendwas zu Hause, was ins Internet angeschlossen ist und nicht euer Computer oder euer WLAN-Radio ist? Dann ruft an und diese Sache mit den Daten. Also jetzt zum Beispiel, wäre es euch wichtig oder egal, ob jemand weiß, wie oft ihr im Monat Spül-Tabs bestellt?
0331 70 97 110 So sieht es nämlich aus.
Genau, weil da wäre jetzt zum Beispiel die Frage, also einmal so ein weiß ja so oder so, wie oft ich Spülmaschinen-Tabs bestelle, wenn ich dort Spülmaschinen-Tabs bestelle. Also die Frage ist ja nicht, ob ich diesen Knopf hab oder nicht, sondern ob ich das online bestelle.
Das macht es halt einfacher. Also wenn ich den Knopf habe, ist natürlich die Kundenbindung viel stärker. Ich muss ja nur noch auf diesen Knopf drücken. Das heißt, ich werde die auch nicht mehr so in der Stadt kaufen, wenn ich da zufällig im Laden bin. Weil ich hole diesen Knopf und damit ist natürlich schon, dadurch, dass ich halt nur noch bei Amazon wahrscheinlich dann kaufe, mehr Daten da.
Na ja und dadurch machst du es halt auch präzise in dem Moment, wo es alles ist. Also sonst würdest du halt sagen, ich wollte mir eh das neue Computerspiel bestellen, dann klicke ich noch eine Kiste Spül-Tabs mit. Werden ja nicht schlecht und so machst du es halt exakt in dem Moment, wo du es aufgebraucht hast. Das heißt, man kann ziemlich genau feststellen, wann bist du damit fertig.
Also warum ist das schlimm, fragt man sich natürlich.
Ja dieser Button ist halt ein sehr einfaches Device, der sagt jetzt noch nicht viel über dich mit Spül-Tabs oder so. Ein Fitness-Tracker zum Beispiel, der deine Pulsrate und noch alles mögliche andere lockt.
Also der Verbindung von Spül-Tabs und Klopapier-Abo könnte man errechnen, ob ich viel zu Hause esse oder nicht.
Oder ob du heutig Partys feierst oder deine Wohnung per Airbnb vermietest.
So, aber was gibt es denn noch für Anwendungen für Internet of Things? Ich bin ein bisschen erschüttert.
Naja, vielleicht eins, was noch sehr aus dem Alltag ist, ist halt sowas wie Carsharing. Also sowas wie ich share meinen Mini irgendwo in der Stadt ab und lauf weg und ein anderer findet den, weil seine App ihm sagt, das Auto hat er im Server des Anbieters gesagt, wo es gerade steht. Und die App sagt mir dann auch, das Auto heißt Claudia und der Tank ist halb voll und es ist grün und es hat übrigens eine Beule vorne an der Stoßstange. Und dann gehst du wieder mit deinem Telefon davor, drückst einen Knopf, die Tür geht auf, wenn du fertig bist, bewertest du es vielleicht noch. Also dieses Zusammenspiel, du interagierst halt mit, diese Maschinen reden alle miteinander und das Auto, gibt es alle seine Statusinformationen ununterbrochen an sein Herrchen. Also für mich ist das jetzt ein positives Beispiel, ist natürlich auch wieder eine Frage, ob du willst, dass eine Firma weiß, wo du so hinfährst, aber der Service wäre vermutlich ohne diese Technologie einfach nicht realisierbar. Also dann wären wir wieder bei so, du musst zu einem festen Ort fahren, wo das Auto wohnt und da jemanden anrufen, wo ist es denn gerade und also das ist ein Positivbeispiel zum Beispiel.
Aber das sagst du jetzt auch so, wie das ist ein Positivbeispiel, gibt es denn auch ein Negativbeispiel? Also ich bin gerade ein bisschen verwirrt, dass ihr nicht mehr sozusagen praktische Anwendungfelder am Start habt für dieses Ding. Also gibt es Internet of Things noch gar nicht, dann ist es so eine hoch abstrakte theoretische Ebene?
Ja, also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin von diesem Thema insofern etwas enttäuscht, weil es immer sehr hochtrabend propagiert wird. Es gab da ja auch diese in dem Zusammenhang diese Geschichte, dass wir jetzt überall RFID-Tags sehen werden. Das ist durchaus der Fall auf industriellem Maßstab, um da schneller Logistik fahren zu können.
Aber auch mit Einschränkungen, weil es in der Praxis nicht so funktioniert, wie es soll.
Genau. Da hängt was woran und macht was schneller?
Naja, das versprechen wir. Wir haben jetzt diese kleinen Chips mit einer kleinen Antenne dran, die ohne Batterie passiv sind. Wenn die in die Reichweite von einem Lesegerät kommen, senden die ihre ID und vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr Informationen, was das da für ein Produkt ist. Und wenn ich das jetzt auf jedem Produkt draufkleben habe und das in der Palette drin ist und ich mit dem Gabelstapler durch so ein großes Antennentor fahre, weiß ich innerhalb von Sekunden, wie viele Gurkengläser, Videorekorder oder sonstige Güter auf dieser Palette geladen sind und ich kann sie direkt im Hochregallager wegräumen und muss die nicht mehr einzeln auspacken und zählen.
Klingt ja auch total spannend.
Oder noch besser oder noch näher beim Verbraucher ist einfach, du sparst dir die Kassen und der Verbraucher braucht halt nicht erst mal anstehen und immer an der falschen Kasse stehen, sondern du läufst auch einfach durch so ein Tor durch und dann sagt der Computer hier bitte einmal Kreditkarte durchswipen und dann bist du halt idealerweise in einer halben Minute mit dem Bezahlvorgang fertig.
Und da gab es halt dann zwei praktische Probleme, zum Beispiel saure Gurken. Also saure Gurken, sie haben dafür gesorgt, dass die ganzen RFID-Tag so gut abgeschirmt waren, dass man nichts anderes mehr gesehen hat, weil dieses Gurkenwasser offensichtlich die Sendefähigkeit komplett geblockt hat. Und teilweise war es auch so, dass wir mit diesem Gabelschlappler in verschiedenen Richtungen durch dieses Tor fahren mussten, weil wenn die Texte falsch ausgerichtet waren auf dem Produkt, dann und das war alles oder nebenan war ein hochregaler Lager von UPS, der dann auf derselben Frequenz und das hat dann in der Praxis zu ganz ganz lustigen Problemen.
Okay, also wir haben heute im aktuellen Chaosradio Folge 218 übrigens schon eine wichtige Sache gelernt, nämlich Gurkenwasser schützt vor Scanner-Strahlung, die RFID-Tags auslesen kann. Also könnt euch mal überlegen, ob ihr vielleicht euren biometrischen Personalausweis in einen Gurkenwasserbad einlegt. Wir machen jetzt erstmal noch eine Musik, die ist von Scar, Heartbreak. Die Herren im Studio überlegen sich mal ein paar Beispiele für das Internet of Things, da reden wir dann gleich noch drüber. Und ihr könnt auch noch gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Dann machen wir erst mal Nachrichten und dann sind wir gleich wieder da.
Die letzten und meisten Tickets für die teilweise schon komplett ausverkauften Konzerte von Marsimoto, Prinz B und Sido. Contra K, Motrip und ein exklusives Radio-Konzert mit Alligatoir.
Einfach gut Fritz hören und gewinnen.
Mehr Infos fritz.de slash rapzember. Rap präsentiert von Fritz.
Ich hab hier ein paar Sachen. Ich hab hier ein paar Sachen. Ich hab hier ein paar Sachen. Ich hab hier ein paar Sachen. Ich hab hier ein paar Sachen. Die Berliner Polizei hat ihre Razzien gegen mutmaßliche Islamisten in Charlottenburg und Britz am Abend beendet. Es seien keine gefährlichen Gegenstände gefunden worden, sagte Polizeipräsident Kant im RWB-Fernsehen. Man habe zuvor einen ernstzunehmenden Hinweis erhalten, dass entsprechende Aktionen in Berlin geplant seien. Am Nachmittag hat ein Großaufgebot der Polizei eine Moschee in Charlottenburg durchsucht. In Britz wurden zwei Männer im Alter von 28 und 46 Jahren festgenommen. Auch Deutschland wird sich am Militäreinsatz gegen die Terror-Miliz IS in Syrien beteiligen. Das hat die Bundesregierung beschlossen, um Frankreich im Anti-Terror-Kampf zu unterstützen. Demnach werden mehrere Aufklärungsflugzeuge der Bundeswehr bereitgestellt. Sie sollen Infos über Angriffsziele in Syrien liefern. Außerdem werden Tankflugzeuge und ein Kriegsschiff der Marine zum Einsatz kommen. Der Bundestag muss noch zustimmen. In Deutschland sind schon jetzt deutlich mehr Flüchtlinge angekommen, als von der Bundesregierung erwartet. Sie hatte bis zum Jahresende mit 800.000 Menschen gerechnet. Die Bundesländer sagen aber, dass es schon fast eine Million Flüchtlinge sind. Demnach kamen allein im November so viele Menschen an, wie noch nie in einem Monat. Die Bundespolizei zielte bis Anfang der Woche mehr als 190.000 Einreisen. In Oranienburg sind vier Weltkriegsbomben auf einmal entdeckt worden. Sie sollen morgen Vormittag entschärft werden. Die Stadt teilte mit, dass die Bomben auf einem Grundstück im Ort Zheilenitz gefunden wurden. Bis 8.30 Uhr morgen früh müssen die Anwohner im Umkreis von einem Kilometer ihre Häuser verlassen. Etwa 4.300 Menschen sind betroffen. In dem Sperrkreis liegt auch der S-Bahnhof Lienitz. Die Bahn will einen Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen einrichten. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, die liegen in Berlin Steglitz bei 1°C, in Friedrichshain sind es 4°C, Grünow meldet 1°C, Ludwigsfelde und Pritzwald jeweils 2°C und in Frankfurt Oder sind es 3°C. Nachts sinken die Temperaturen, um die 0°C kriegen wir in Berlin und Brandenburg und dazu kann es neblig sein. Morgen lockert es im Tagesverlauf auf und es soll überwiegend sonnig werden, bei maximal 4 bis 6°C. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100 Stadtring Richtung Neukölln. Die Überleitung zum Abzweig Steglitz ist wegen einer Baustelle bis morgen früh gesperrt. Aus Brandenburg haben wir keine Meldungen, eine Meldung aber noch zu Berliner S-Bahn. Auf der Linie S5 fahren zwischen Strausberg und Strausberg Nord bis Sonntag Busse statt Bahn. Da wo es geht, euch ne gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr eine Frage oder Kritik oder Lob oder ein schönes Foto, Video oder eine Sprachnachricht oder einfach mal Grüße ins Fritz Studio schicken wollt, dann macht das doch. Und schon seid ihr mittendrin und im Radio mit der Studio Message in eurer Fritz App.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo es heute um das Internet of Things geht. Und da begrüßen wir recht herzlich den Peter. Den Danimo. Und den Mutax. Vorm Chaos Computer Club. Und die wollen uns ein bisschen erzählen, was das mit dem Internet of Things auf sich hat, was da die Gefahren sind, was cool ist und was da vielleicht da auswerten kann. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon gelernt, was ein IT-Gipfel ist. Das ist deshalb in dem Zusammenhang wichtig, weil da auch über das Internet of Things gesprochen wurde. Wir haben gelernt, was das Internet of Things ganz grob ist, nämlich einfach Dinge, die im Internet hängen, aber keine so Vollcomputer sind, also sowas wie Smartphone oder halt Laptop. Und Gurkenwasser schützt vor RFID-Ablese-Strahlung. Das ist wirklich eine wichtige Nachricht. Dann wollte ich wissen, was jetzt genauso Beispiele sind für das Internet of Things. Und da haben sich die Herren mir ein bisschen schwer getan, aber wir werden gleich nochmal genauer darüber sprechen, was das genau praktisch bedeutet, also was da die Hersteller wollen, was ihr kauft. Und wir haben auch einen Anruf. Ihr könnt mich heute auch anrufen und sagen, wie viel Daten ihr bereit seid aufzugeben für ein bequemeres Leben oder was ihr euch an Internet of Things zu Hause eingebaut habt. Oder vielleicht habt ihr einen anderen Begriff in diesem Zusammenhang gehört. Wenn es darum geht, dass der Kühlschrank später demnächst selber steht, Smart Home. Und da genau hat der Michael was zu sagen. Aus dem Friedrichshain, 24 Jahre alt, hallo und guten Abend. So, Internet of Things, warum sagt ihr das was?
Wie bitte?
Internet of Things, warum sagt ihr das was?
Naja, weil ich zu Hause mir vor zwei Monaten mir Smart Home installiert habe. Damit kann man halt Heizkosten und Stromkosten ein bisschen senken. Das Ganze funktioniert halt über mein Smartphone, wo ich dann, wenn ich jetzt mal zur Arbeit gehe, einfach die Heizung dann runterdrehe. Oder wenn ich veressen habe, den Herd auszumachen oder irgendwas, dass ich es darüber dann halt auch ausmachen kann. Das zeigt mir dann halt auch an, wie viele Steckdosen ich in einer Wohnung drinne habe und wie viele Heizkörper.
Wie genau hat das funktioniert? Was musstest du installieren, bevor das alles so geklappt hat?
Und zwar, ich musste die ganzen Steckdosen austauschen. Ich habe mir das von Wattenfall bestellt, dieses ganze Set. Vom Monteur mussten die Heizungsdrehungen, also diese Fühler ausgetauscht werden und musste dann alles ans WLAN sozusagen angebunden werden.
Das heißt, alle deine Thermostate hängen am WLAN und auch die ganze Steuerung der Einzelkomponenten erfolgt über WLAN?
Genau, genau.
Das heißt, wenn dein Internet kaputt ist, dann kannst du dein Heizungsthema bedienen. Also, Anlassbürokrat, geht das auch noch von Hand?
Von Hand geht das auch. Falls das WLAN kaputt geht, dann kann ich das noch per Hand sozusagen noch steuern. Aber das merkt das System schon, wenn irgendwas im WLAN eine Störung ist, dass dann halt auch keine Daten mehr, beziehungsweise keine Daten mehr gesendet werden. Ja, und ich das dann halt auf meinen Smartphone halt auch nicht mit bekomme. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt auf Fernverkehr bin und ich merke in Berlin Stromausfall, das teilt mir die App auch gleich sofort mit.
Hast du mal die Situation gehabt, dass das Internet ausgefallen ist und funktioniert dann trotzdem noch alles? Also dass dein WLAN vollkommen in Ordnung ist, aber dass zum Beispiel dein Service Provider Probleme hat. Funktioniert das dann oder kommt das ohne eine Internetverbindung nicht aus?
Das Problem ist, das kommt ohne eine Internetverbindung nicht aus. Das heißt, wenn irgendwo ein Verteiler für Internet kaputt ist, bzw. ein Geschlagen ist, das war ja jetzt mal der Fall, dass dieser Verteiler von der Telekom durchgeschmort ist, dann habe ich natürlich dann keinen Zugriff, außer halt nur noch manuell.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, du sparst damit oder kannst damit sparen. Ist das was, was dir versprochen wurde von der Werbung? Oder hast du da schon ganz konkret gemerkt, ok, du verbrauchst jetzt irgendwie was weniger?
Ich habe ja an der Heizung so eine Ableser und ich habe ja, wenn ich dann halt außer Hause gegangen bin, habe ich natürlich die Heizung auf drei gelassen und habe aber dann im Laufe der Zeit, wo ich es jetzt halt installiert habe, gemerkt, doch, ich kann doch gar eine Menge sparen. Also ich habe da an diesem, wo man es halt abliest, denn halt, dass es viel, viel weniger ist. so 10% weniger ist, auf den Monat gerechnet.
Heizung oder hast du auch Strom-Einsparungen? Weil ich stelle mir vor, dass wenn du da jetzt quasi Strom-Steckdosen austauschen musstest, dann war ja wohl auch das Versprechen, dass sich da am Stromverbrauch was ändert.
Ja, Stromverbrauch ist nicht so dolle, da war ich ein bisschen enttäuscht. Es ist wirklich nur so für den Notfall, falls man wirklich vergessen hat, irgendwo Licht auszumachen oder irgendwie den Fernseher. Weil mein Fernseher hatte mal die Macke, dass er einfach mal wieder angegangen ist. Aber ansonsten, was Strom angeht, kann ich jetzt noch nicht so beurteilen. Zeitskosten ja, aber Stromkosten hab ich jetzt nicht so.
Und noch eine letzte Frage, deine Daten, wobei wird das gesteuert? Musstest du da bei Wattenfall auch noch einen Account anlegen oder sowas?
Ja, da muss ich mir einen Account anlegen. Da gilt halt auch nur für Wattenfallkunde. Also man ist sozusagen an Wattenfall gebunden. Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach woanders. Da muss man dann halt auch Vertragsnummer und so weiter und so fort. Und den Vorteil hat noch, es kommt nicht immer jemand zum Ablesen.
Naja, also bei mir kommt auch niemand zum Ablesen, weil der im Keller hängt. Aber es ist ja schon ein bisschen krass. Du kannst also jetzt deinen Stromanbietern im Nachhinein nicht mehr wechseln. Und wenn du es machst, dann kannst du deine Heizung und dein Licht nicht mehr steuern.
Also ich sag jetzt mal, die Heizung läuft ja eh über Wattenfall. Da kann ich ja nichts dran ändern. Aber was den Strom angeht, da bin ich dann sozusagen gebunden. Hab aber dafür, dass ich es installiert habe, dann halt noch einen Bonus bekommen, dass ich die Kilowattstunde um einen Cent spare.
Also du musstest nichts dafür bezahlen? Und musstest du was dafür bezahlen, dass du es installiert hast?
Ja, ich musste was dafür bezahlen. Man kann sich aber das alles wieder über die Steuererklärung wieder reinholen.
Und du findest es sehr bequem?
Und ich finde das sehr bequem. Was denn die Frage stellt, ist dann halt mit dem Datenschutz. Weil mir ist dann halt auch so aufgefallen, dass das nicht so ganz verschlüsselt übertragen wird.
Wie ist dir das aufgefallen?
Bei meinem Browser, den ich habe, da zeigt es ja dann immer an, dass es halt so und so verschlüsselt ist. Und das ist da in diesem Fall nicht so. Aber da hat Wattenfall versprochen, dass da eine Änderung vorgenommen wird. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt auch mal mein Smartphone verliere, könnte ein Fremder, trotz wenn das alles runterlöscht, könnte trotzdem ein Fremder mir, sei ich jetzt mal zuhause, mir einfach mal die Zeitung auf volle Pulle stellen, weil das dann so eine Art Branding ist.
Okay, das war ein Erfahrungsbericht über Smart Home. Michael, vielen Dank. Ja. Und wir werden auf jeden Fall das Datenschutzzimmer, glaube ich, auch hier gleich noch mal genauer besprechen. Aber auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch mit deiner Smart Home Entscheuerung. Ich weiß doch gar nicht, ob das ein Fluch oder ein Kompliment ist. So, und dann haben wir noch den Christopher. Christopher 22 kommt aus Tübingen. Hallo Christopher.
Hallo.
Was hast du dir denn angeschafft an smarten Dingen?
Also meine erste Berührung mit den Internet of Things waren so fernsteilbare Steckdosen, also die man sich so zwischen die Steckdosen in den Stecker steckt und dann per App an- und ausschalten kann oder per Fernsteuerung über Automatisierung. Und ich fand das ziemlich ernüchternd, weil die wirklich nicht funktioniert haben.
Wieso? Was haben die gemacht stattdessen?
Ja, die sind irgendwie einfach mal an- oder ausgegangen oder haben nicht zur speziellen Zeit eingeschaltet. Also ich fand dieses Internet of Things zu Anfang sehr ernüchternd, weil das einfach nicht so glatt alles gelaufen ist. Wahrscheinlich, weil ich es mir nicht selber zusammengehackt habe, sondern das Profil des Heeres gekauft habe. Aber es hat nicht so funktioniert, wie ich es mir gewünscht habe.
Wie wurden die angestellt? Auch über WLAN dann wahrscheinlich?
Ja, über das WLAN. Also man kann die auch über IFTT, also diese Automatisierungswebdienst automatisieren. Und der hatte dann nochmal 15 Minuten Verzögerung. Und ich hatte mir dann so gedacht, okay, dann bin ich irgendwie vor meiner Haustür und dann geht meine Kaffeemaschine an und dann hat es aber nochmal eine halbe Stunde gedauert, dass es dann reagiert hat und gedacht hat, dass ich zu Hause bin. Und das war alles nicht so, wie ich mir das gewünscht habe.
Okay, das heißt, du hast das jetzt einmal ausprobiert und damit hat sich das Thema für dich erledigt?
Ja, also die liegen jetzt bei mir rum. Vielleicht muss ich mir nochmal genau anschauen, aber ich fand das alles noch sehr unausgegoren. Meine zweite Beherung allerdings, da bin ich etwas zufriedener mit, ist dieses Fitbit, was du vorhin erwähnt hast.
Was ist das genau? Also ich weiß jetzt nur, dass das irgendwie so ein Armband ist, was irgendwie Körperdingen misst.
Ja, also das ist, genau, es gibt es verschiedene Ausführungen. Ich hab das jetzt mit, in der sozusagen, in der höherklassigen Variante mit Pulsfrequenzmessung. Also es misst dann, glaub ich, alle 5 Sekunden automatisch deinen Puls. Und wenn du es per Bluetooth an dein Handy verbunden hast, dann wird das auch alles aufgezeichnet. Und dann kannst du auch noch so ein Training anstellen. Dann wird sogar die Frequenzmessung auf einmal die Sekunde erhöht, dass du wie an einem Training eine genauere Pulsaufzeichnung hast. Und dann zeichnen die auch noch so Schritte und Kalorien auf. Und was ja viele sagen, ist, dass man dadurch mehr läuft, wenn man ja diese 10.000 Schritte pro Tag erreichen will. Und das ist wirklich, wirklich schon ein Ansporn. Also damit bin ich eher zufrieden. Dabei habe ich jetzt eine Frage, ist das nicht eher das Bluetooth of Things? Weil dieses Fitbit direkt ist ja nicht mit dem Internet verbunden, sondern nur mit meinem Handy.
Naja, das ist letztendlich ja das Gleiche wie, ob dein Smartphone jetzt mit dem WLAN, mit dem Internet verbunden ist oder hier halt, dass Bluetooth dann die Verbindung über dein Handy nutzt. Ein Internet of Things Device muss halt nicht zwangsläufig seinen eigenen Internetanschluss mitbringen. Das wird in der Zukunft immer mehr werden, einfach weil Modems und so kleiner und billiger werden. Aber momentan, also wenn du jetzt in deinem Fitbit auch einen GSM-Modem oder so drin hättest, dann kannst du es halt wahrscheinlich alle drei Stunden laden und das wäre irgendwie deutlich schwerer, sodass es sich halt noch das Internet bei deinem Telefon leit. Aber letztendlich kommuniziert es ja bei das Internet, es ist nur noch ein Stück dazwischen.
Diese Daten, die sich da ansammeln, hast du die nur bei dir zu Hause auf dem Telefon oder so? Oder werden die auch auf einem Server abgespeichert? Also gibt es da einen angeschlossenen Online-Dienst?
Da gibt es einen angeschlossenen Online-Dienst. Also das kann man sich dann auf dem Browser anschauen und alles Mögliche damit machen. Also das ist frei im Internet, halt bei Fitbit gespeichert. Und die gehen damit auch ziemlich harsh um. Also es gibt da noch so Premiumdienste. Und die rücken dann auch nicht alle Daten raus, die man damit sammelt. Das ist einer der größten Kritikpunkte, dass man da irgendwelche Premiumdienste dazukaufen kann, die dann das nochmal genauer auswerten. Und da ausschließlich einfach, dass da Daten gesammelt werden, die dem Endnutzer dann gar nicht zur Verfügung gestellt wird, wenn er nicht noch über den Gerätepreis monatlich Geld ausgibt.
Und du machst aber trotzdem mit?
Ich mach da trotzdem mit. Also ich hab das jetzt und ja, bringt das nichts, wenn ich das jetzt nicht trage, aufs Protest. Ich hab ja jetzt schon Geld ausgegeben. Und ja, was ich noch mache, ist, dass ich über Move mal alle meine Bewegungen aufzeichne, über mein iPhone. Ist ja eigentlich auch im Grunde Internet of Things. Also alles ist ja Internet of Things. Es geht da nicht irgendwie Internet of People, weil da gibt es noch alle Tipps im Kopf.
Das Internet of Things ist schon, da geht es halt genau um die Geräte, die online sind, die nicht dein Smartphone sind und nicht dein Computer. Okay, dann Christopher, vielen Dank für den Einblick in das Internet of Things-Leben und viel Spaß damit noch. Und das ist ja aber anscheinend auch so eine grundsätzliche Frage. Man hat so ein Internetthing und das kommuniziert dann nochmal mit einem Online-Service. Muss das so?
Na, nicht zwangsläufig. Also grundsätzlich kannst du die Infrastruktur technisch dafür natürlich auch selber betreiben. Also zum Beispiel bei diesen Smart Home, meistens sehr Smart Home Produkte, hast du zum Beispiel da mehr oder weniger einen vollwertigen Computer zu Hause stehen, mit dem deine ganzen Steckdosen und so reden und dieser Computer redet dann mit der Cloud. Also meistens ist das so eine Box, sieht aus wie so ein DSL-Router oder sowas. Und diese Box könnte technisch gesehen natürlich auch vollkommen alleine funktionieren. Aber dann hast du ja genau das, was die beiden Anrufe auch schon beschrieben haben, diesen Wender-Login. Also Wattenfall möchte, dass du bei Wattenfall bleibst und Fitbit möchte ja auch, dass du bei Fitbit bleibst und dein nächstes Fitbit kaufst und den Premium-Dienst dazu kaufst. Wenn du das aber jetzt alles bei dir zuhause hättest, dann gäbe es ja gar keinen Grund, warum sie dir das Gerät vielleicht auch günstig überlassen sollen. Es ist halt immer der Frage, was ist der Business Case hinter dem, der es dir verkauft?
Na, wie ist denn der bei Internet of Things? Der ist quasi eigentlich nie, wir bringen dein Gerät für dich online und du gibst uns Geld dafür, sondern er ist immer, wir sammeln deine Daten oder wie?
Ich würde sagen, bei solchen Angeboten wie, wir haben hier so WLAN-Lampen, die du dir installieren kannst und es gibt diese App, mit der du sie steuern kannst. Natürlich gibt es WLAN-Lampen.
Was machen die genau?
Na ja, das ist so eine Lampe, eine LED-Glübürne mit E27-Fassung, schraubst du da in eine Deckenlampe und kannst dann per App die Farben frei wählen.
Ob es nur eine Steckdose oder eine Lampe ist, ist ja letztendlich das Gleiche.
Und da gibt es halt verschiedene Produkte, es gibt Produkte, die dann so quasi offline bei dir zu Hause arbeiten, du hast dann so ein Gateway und da sind dann so die Lichtszenen drauf gespeichert, dann kannst du sagen, ich hab jetzt einen schönen Kinoabend, dann wird das Licht schön gedimmt und alle Lampen sind so synchron, dass es eine schöne Lichtstimmung gibt. Und da gibt es auch Dienste, wo du das in der App sagst, die schickt das an den Server und der Server hat dann deine Lichtszene gespeichert und der kommuniziert mit deinen Lampen und 20 Sekunden später, wenn du Glück hast, ändern die dann auch mal ihre Farbe oder so oder auch nicht, wenn das Internet gerade ausgefallen ist. Also ich glaube, da gibt es schon auch sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen von den Herstellern, was natürlich auch, also wenn du dich wenn nicht offline haben möchtest, ohne Hilfverbindung brauche ich eben noch eine Zusatzbox, die da irgendwo steht und momentan ist der Ansatz, na ich hab halt hier diese Glühbirne, die schraube ich rein und die braucht kein weiteres Gerät und hat WLAN und du kannst dann direkt mit dem Ding reden.
Aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch dann sozusagen sehr attraktiv für den Nutzer. Also weil er muss halt nicht zu Hause stehen, wo er sich drum kümmern muss, der kann halt wie gesagt die Glühbirne reinschrauben, App installieren, fertig. Ist doch eigentlich praktisch oder nicht?
Ja die meisten dieser Produkte, die dann auch offline funktionieren, sind halt auch direkt einen Tacken teurer, also diese Offline-Glühbirnen kosten meistens so spaßiger 80 Euro, was für eine Glühbirne ja auch schon eine Hausnummer ist. Wenn du jetzt die an die Cloud hängen würdest und der Anbieter dir vielleicht Werbung auf deiner Glühbirne einblenden könnte oder sonst was, dann würdest du diese Glühbirne wahrscheinlich für 15 Euro kaufen oder vielleicht sogar geschenkt bekommen. Ist letztendlich wie bei allen Dingen, wenn derjenige für den Dienst kein Geld von dir verlangt, will er irgendwas anderes haben, weil dem seine Server kosten Strom, dem seine Mitarbeiter kosten Strom, die Entwicklung, nee die Mitarbeiter kosten Geld, die Entwicklung kostet Geld und...
Vielleicht ist alles Roboter.
Ja, aber letztendlich entweder sind es Daten oder Geld oder irgendwas anderes, warum sie es für dich betreiben.
Ratet ihr eigentlich vom Internet of Things jetzt so grundsätzlich ab oder zu oder ist das so...
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Unterschied Prinzip und was man draus macht. Und das Prinzip Internet of Things ist natürlich irgendwie reizvoll. Da haben wir ja in der ersten halben Stunde vor allen Dingen irgendwie die positiven Geschichten erzählt, die wir erzählt haben. Wir haben natürlich noch ein paar, die dann eher so klingen, als wäre das nicht so toll.
Zum Abgewöhnen meinst du?
Das ist die weniger diplomatische Variante. Nein, aber im Prinzip sowas, wie auch gerade der Anrufer beschrieben hat, lass mal irgendwie die komplette Wohnung steuern und ich komme heim. Und eine halbe Stunde bevor ich zu Hause bin, entweder weil ich es eingestellt habe oder weil mein Telefon mit GPS weiß, wie weit ich von meinem Zuhause weg bin oder dass ich mich gerade auf mein Zuhause zubewege. Und dann wird einfach mal die Heizung angemacht. Also wer gerade reinkommt und die Heizung ist nicht an dieser Tage weiß, was ich meine. Eigentlich eine sehr schöne Geschichte.
Und das coole ist, das kann man alles komplett datensparsam machen. Das heißt, das Telefon weiß, wo es ist. Ich muss nicht mit dem Google-Dienst reden. Das Telefon muss nicht ständig updaten, wo es ist und ein Google-Server muss entscheiden, dass der jetzt gerade auf dem Weg nach Hause ist. Sondern das Telefon hat ja den Kalender lokal, das weiß, wo ich nicht gerade unterwegs bin. Das könnte tatsächlich mit mir zu Hause reden, wenn wir da so smarte Devices hätten, die auch eine offene Schnittstelle haben. Also wo ich dann eben nicht auf einzelne Anbieter festgenagelt wäre. Klar, wenn ich mir alles jetzt von Google kaufe, das Nest-Thermostat und dann auch bei Google mein Kalender habe und mit Android alles schön synchronisiere, dann sagt mir das schon, dass ich mich jetzt auf den Weg machen muss, weil ich hier irgendwie Blue Moon Gast bin und dass die aktuelle Verkehrslage mir empfiehlt, also ich sollte jetzt mich auf den Weg machen, dass ich pünktlich ankomme. Das ist schon alles sehr, sehr verlockend. Aber es geht halt immer mehrere Wege, wie man zu dem Ziel kommt. Das eine ist eben die Variante, ich habe alle Daten, zentral bei einem Dienstleister, der weiß dann alles über mich. Oder ich habe vielleicht ein bisschen komplexeres System, dafür die Daten aber auch nur da, wo ich sie brauche. Das heißt, ich habe eben meinen Router zu Hause, der sowieso läuft und der hat halt dann noch so ein Gateway für diese ganze Hauungautomatio.
Ja, also gerade wo du jetzt googeltest, es verlässt für mich so ein bisschen das konkrete Smart Home oder Internet of Things. Aber es gibt so eine Stelle, wo das für mich, wo so diese Waage dann umkippt, wo ich dazwischen ich gebe gar nichts von mir preis und es ist halt vielleicht doch ein bisschen praktisch. Und das ist Google Maps. Ich habe viele verschiedene Navis ausprobiert. Und es ist einfach so, Google Maps sagt mir relativ zuverlässig, wo ich hin muss und wie die Verkehrs-Situation dahin ist. Und natürlich geht das nur, weil ich auch meine Daten freigebe. Und ich weiß auch, Google ist eine Firma, die so viel Daten wie möglich sozusagen ansammelt. Aber der Service ist sozusagen so gut, dass ich denke so. Und ich kann es mir halt von mir selber auch so rechtfertigen. Ich sage, naja, wenn ich meine Daten in das System gebe, kann dann auch für andere wieder berechnet werden, wie der Verkehr ist und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen nutze ich das. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es gerade bei diesen ganzen anderen Sachen auch so ist, dass die Leute halt sagen, okay, ja, meine Daten fallen da an, aber es ist halt so unglaublich praktisch.
Aber das Argument, was du gerade bringst, ist eigentlich ganz spannend, weil das ist nämlich, weil ich einen Vorteil habe, den man ja durchaus Google geben könnte. Man könnte ja sagen, okay, dann sammeln wir entweder einen Hersteller oder man packt das in einen gemeinsamen Pool von Daten, denen sich mehrere Hersteller greifen können. Für die gebe ich, weil ich das gut finde, das frei. Und von mir aus kann das auch erst mal voreingestellt sein. Da wäre natürlich irgendwie eine gewisse Datensparsamkeit schön, aber ist halt schwierig. Aber was du ja sagst, ist, weil ich dieses eine Feature habe, toleriere ich alle anderen Schweinereien mal freundlich ausgedrückt. Die da durchaus per Default erst mal eingestellt sind und der sich viele einfach erst mal nicht bewusst sind, dass diese Daten irgendwie exportiert werden. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich mit meinem Siri, Quartana, wie sie nicht alle heißen, rede. Vielen Leuten ist, glaube ich, gar nicht bewusst, dass das nicht auf dem Handy prozessiert wird, sondern dass das erst mal in die Cloud läuft.
Bei Google ist es aber tatsächlich spannend, weil ich habe das nie gemacht, weil ich diesen Service nicht benutzt habe. Man kann sich diese Anfragen nicht runterladen.
Man kann auch einstellen, dass sie gespeichert werden. Man kann auch einstellen, dass sie gelöscht werden sollen. Meine werden gelöscht. Aber man kann sich die Samples anhören.
Wir wandern gerade ein bisschen vom Thema weg, aber es ist nicht ganz unspannend. Wenn ihr diesen Service benutzt, dass ihr mit eurem Telefon sprecht und sagt, hier Siri, ruf irgendjemand an. Oder bei Google, wie heißt sie?
Google auch, glaube ich.
Genau, hey Google, oder wie das da geht. Okay Google. Dann wird tatsächlich das aufgenommen, also als Audio und bei Google gespeichert. Und das kann man sich dann wieder runterladen und sich selber zuhören. Man hat doch die ganze History. Das ist tatsächlich auch ein bisschen spannend. Das sind natürlich auch Daten, die die ganzen Unternehmen haben. Also, wir sind jetzt an dem Punkt, wo man so sagt, na, ist das nicht vielleicht irgendwie ein Argument, dass man sagt, manche Dinge macht man noch, manche nicht. Ihr könnt gerne noch anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110, wenn ihr auch eine Meinung zum Thema habt und sagt, nee, ich bin da ganz hart, ich will niemals irgendwelche Daten angeben. Oder ihr sagt, ich finde das alles super bequem, soll eine Art ist wissen, weil ich kann mich dann zurücklehnen. Wir hören solange, während ihr vielleicht eure Telefon herauskramt, folgt der Wox mit der Web und sind gleich wieder da. Und damit willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo Menschen aus dem Chaos Computer Club zu Gast sind und Dinge mit Internet erklären. Heute mit dem Internet of Things. Und wir heißen herzlich willkommen den Peter. Hallo und guten Abend. Den Dani Mo. Hallo. Und den Mutags.
Abend.
Wir haben schon gelernt, was Internet of Things ist und mein Lieblingsfaktor der Abend, dass Gurkenwasser voll aufs lese Strahlung schützt. Das Internet of Things sind Dinge, die man ins Internet tut und die dann den Haushalt bequemer machen können. Zum Beispiel Lampen hab ich gelernt, Steckdosen gehen, sogar der Herd, all das kann man ans Internet anschließen. Dann ist so die Frage, wie steuert man das? Dann kann man das einerseits steuern, wenn die ganze Technik zu Hause ist und andererseits, wenn uns Anbieter dann anbieten, na hier, du kriegst nur das Gerät, wir kümmern uns um den Rest und dann kriegen wir auch deine Daten, weil das ist ja auch ganz schön cool. Und da fragen sich manche Leute natürlich so, na, ist das so eine gute Idee, wenn der jetzt ganz genau weiß, wann ich meine Steckdose an- und ausschalte und Dinge tue oder vielleicht auch lasse. Und ich glaube, Kenny gehört auch dazu. Kenny ist 23, kommt aus Berlin. Hallo Kenny. Du wolltest etwas zu Smart Home sagen, was denn?
Ja genau, also wie ihr schon gesagt habt, mit dem Licht und diesen ganzen wunderschönen Gadgets, die einem das Leben leichter machen, finde ich ja eine ganz tolle Sache. Ist auch richtig, nur manchmal macht mir das echt auch Angst. Also ich habe diese Lampen gekauft von Philips und die funktionieren super. Die funktionieren mir mit Geo-Tracking, das heißt, wenn ich auf einer gewissen Strecke zu meinem Haus bin, gehen die an oder aus, je nachdem was ich eingestellt habe. Was mir aber bei Geo-Tracking dann echt Angst macht, ist, dass mein Smartphone mir anzeigt, wie viele Minuten ich jetzt von dem Standpunkt nach Hause brauche, bei normalen Verkehr. Das hast du bei Google angesprochen hattest. Ja, das ist mir letztens immer aufgefallen, ich fahre eine gewisse Strecke, relativ oft zur Arbeit oder zu der Freundin oder so. Und ich stelle mein Auto dann ab. Und wenn ich dann wieder an dem Punkt bin, wo mein Auto abgestellt wurde, sagt mir mein iPhone, so und so vier Minuten brauchst du jetzt, obwohl du nicht weißt, dass ich mit dem Auto fahren möchte, nach Hause. Und das ist, seitdem ich dieses Geo-Checking aktiviert habe, bei meinen Lampen bzw. bei meiner Heizung, macht es das. Und das finde ich echt ziemlich bedenklich.
Also quasi das iPhone beobachtet dich einfach nur und hat halt festgestellt, wenn du an diesem Ort bist, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass du jetzt dort hin willst und deswegen sagt sie das.
Oder wie? Genau, also ich wusste ja, dass Apple beliebte Orte, heißt das bei Apple glaube ich, Daten sammelt. Das kann man ausstellen, das ist auch kein Geheimnis. Aber das ist dann so, ich finde offensiv, die eine Push-Up-Benachrichtigung aufs Handy sendet, finde ich, also woher weiß es, dass ich nur, weil ich jetzt am Auto bin, wieder mit dem Auto fahren möchte.
Google macht sowas ähnliches auch, das sagt dir dann, wo du dein Auto geparkt hast. Also es erkennt, dass du aufgehört hast, dich mit einer Geschwindigkeit zu bewegen. Und wenn du dann zurückkommst vom Einkaufen, sagt das dir, wo dein Auto steht. Und manchmal funktioniert es nicht richtig, dann sagt es einem auch, wo das Flugzeug steht, wenn man gelandet ist. Das ist dann ganz lustig. Aber die machen das auch. Das wird dann auch nicht lokal gespeichert, sondern irgendwo auf einem Server.
Und das zum Beispiel ist, von dem Beispiel, was ich vorhin erzählt habe, ist es das Gegenteil. Ich bin so ein Typ, ich fahre manchmal Auto und dann relativ lange Strecken wie der öffentliche Nahverkehrsmittel. Und mein Wohngebiet ist relativ dicht bewohnt. Das heißt, es gibt so drei, vier Standardparkplätze. Aber wenn ich das Auto da nicht abgestellt habe, dann weiß ich nicht, wo es ist. Dann muss ich halt wirklich suchen. Und da habe ich auch immer gehört, es gibt so Apps, die halt die messen. Also du stellst halt an, dass die dich überwachen und dann messen die einfach irgendwie die Geschwindigkeit. Das heißt, die erkennen, wann du Auto fährst und wann du nicht mehr Auto fährst. Und machen dann genau dieses Ding. Können dir sagen, wo du dein Auto zum letzten Mal geparkt hast. Und das wäre eigentlich so super praktisch, weil es wirklich einmal im Monat vorkommt, als ich mein verdammtes Auto suche. Aber andererseits ist es mir auch zu gruselig. Also ich möchte nicht, dass eine App mich überwacht und sozusagen und online irgendwo abspeichert, wie mein komplettes Bewegungsprofil ist. Ich habe mich jetzt aber vorher dagegen entschieden. Du Kenny hast dich ja sozusagen dafür entschieden, das zu machen, aber findest es trotzdem komisch. Was ist denn jetzt das komische Gefühl bei dir?
Das Ding ist, das hat es ja nicht.
Also ich habe mir diese Produkte für die Lampe geholt und habe dann entschieden, bzw. auch für die Heizung und habe jetzt im Winter entschieden, bzw. wenn ich jetzt lange nicht zu Hause bin, dass ich dann halt meine Geräte übers Internet steuern kann. So Heizung oder Licht oder... Ich habe auch überlegt, mir auch mal so eine schöne Webcam zu organisieren, aber eigentlich nur Spielerei. Aber seitdem ich mir halt entschieden habe, dass mein Licht angehen soll, wenn ich 50 Meter vor meiner Haustür bin, sozusagen, seitdem ich dieses Geo-Tracking aktiviert habe, ist mein Handy, also der Anbieter Apple, schickt mir diese Push-Up-Nachricht. Seitdem macht das Handy das ja. Und das ist, ich weiß nicht, auch heute die Meldung, jeder guckt 80 Mal auf seine Apple Watch. Also ich gucke definitiv weniger auf meine Apple Watch, aber welche Daten veranlassen jetzt Apple, so was rauszuhauen?
Ich glaube, die Apple Watch hat so ein Ding, wenn du den Arm nach oben drehst, also das Display nach oben geht, dass erkennt man diese Bewegung.
Ja, aber die befragen ja nicht die Leute, sondern sie sammeln die Daten der Uhr.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und das heißt ja, dass mein Handy, Apple, greift auf eine fremde App zu und hat dadurch ja irgendwie eine Kompetenz.
Ist es nicht umgedreht, ist es nicht so, dass die App beim Handy abfragt, wo bist du gerade?
Nein, also bei diesem Philips-Tuning musste ich mich online anmelden. Auf der Hinterseite musste ich das Geo-Tracking aktivieren, damit die mein Haus sozusagen orten können. Weil ich habe ja auch diesen Zwischenrouter hier im Haus, damit es funktioniert. Und ich weiß nicht auf welches Datenmaterial sie zugreifen, aber es müsste ja auch mit Samsung funktionieren.
Nochmal was?
Also ich weiß nicht auf welches Datenmaterial Philips zugreift, und dann ob die eine eigene Map haben oder von TomTom oder was weiß ich.
Eine Karte brauchen sie ja nicht. Die können einfach über die Schnittstellen vom Handy, also die Mobilbetriebssysteme haben ja alle Schnittstellen, wo man dann anfragen kann als App, wo bin ich gerade, wo bewege ich mich. Und ich denke mal, dass in dem Zuge auch Apple natürlich jetzt dadurch, dass eine Applikation regelmäßig deine Location pollt, natürlich auch Apple das Profil wesentlich dichter hat. Also die Handys machen es auch so, dass sie den Aufenthaltsort nur dann wirklich fein granular ermitteln, wenn eine Applikation gerade den auch haben möchte und ansonsten eben nur so grob tracken. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass in dem Zuge Apple da eben jetzt auch mehr Daten bekommt, weil das eben im Betriebssystem aktiv ist. Aber da bin ich jetzt auch kein App-Profi.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, als ich das erste Mal gesehen habe, hat es mich schon echt erstaunt, was heutzutage so alles an Daten.
Was ich spannend finde, ist, du hättest ja jederzeit die Möglichkeit, zu sagen, ich mache es nicht mehr, sondern ich steuere meine Lampen nur von Hand und mache die Ordnungskontakt. Das machst du aber nicht, also so sehr stört sich dann doch nicht, oder? Also es ist ein unangenehmes Gefühl, aber es ist nur ein bisschen unangenehm.
Das ist halt, man macht nicht seine Gedanken. Aber andererseits denkt man sich auch, okay, wenn jemand wirklich meine Daten haben wollen würde, in irgendeiner Art und Weise und so interessant bin ich halt einfach nicht. Ich bin ein kleines Licht in Berlin, sag ich mal. Dann würde der auch durch andere Wege auf meine Daten zugreifen. Ich mache es derjenigen Personen oder dem Unternehmen halt einfacher. Okay, gut, aber und liebe Quemlichkeit ist es dann natürlich. Also abends im Bett zu liegen und nicht noch mal aufzustehen zum Lichtschalter zu gehen, sondern einfach auf der App auf ausdrücken.
Nee, das meine ich nicht. Du könntest ja diese App benutzen, aber deine Lampen nur noch per App manuell steuern, also manuell per App sozusagen und nicht mehr dieses Ordnungsding machen. Das ginge ja auch.
Das ginge auch, ja. Aber das ist dann trotzdem die Bequemlichkeit, eine warme Heizung zu haben oder Licht schon anzuhaben, wenn man ins Haus kommt.
Also du willst nicht nur von ferne Steuern können, du willst auch nicht mehr dran denken müssen.
Richtig, weil ich auch einen Kopf voll mit anderen Dingen habe und so ein kleines Helferchen machen lassen natürlich.
Tja, und so verkauft er seine Seele an dem Teufel.
Entschuldigung, kurze dramatische Untermalung der Geschehnisse.
Das ist vollkommen richtig. Ich habe meine Seele schon damals verkauft, als ich mir mein erstes iPhone bild habe. Mittlerweile habe ich glaube ich fast alles von Apple. Also von daher, ich bin sowieso nicht rettbar.
Alles klar.
Hast du schon irgendwie neue Anschaffungen noch geplant? Was kommt als nächstes?
Na, also die Apple Watch war jetzt das letzte.
Ich meine so Smart Home Internet of Things mäßig, nicht ein Apple Produktkategorie vervollständigen.
Na ja, die smarte Waschmaschine ist dann das nächste bestimmt, wenn die dann auf den Markt kommt.
Aber da frage ich mich auch mal, was soll denn daran smart sein? Es hilft mir nicht, dass ich die von ferne ansteuern kann.
Na doch, du kannst sie anmachen, damit sie fertig ist, wenn du zu Hause bist.
Also bei meiner Waschmaschine zu Hause kann ich sagen, hier, mach dich voll und dann starte bitte so und so viel Zeit.
Ja, aber vielleicht kann sie sich erst einschalten, wenn der Strompreis günstig ist nachts, damit die Nachbarn maximal genervt werden.
Was ich aber wirklich interessant finde, und das ist jetzt kein Scherz, das ist der Kühlschrank, der mit Internetzugriff, dem du erlaubst, Essen nachzubestellen oder Produkte, die halt da sind.
Aber der wird uns ja versprochen, seit es die Idee davon gibt.
Ja, und auch seit sechs Jahren den Flughafen schon versprochen.
Warte, der Kühlschrank of Things ist der Flughafen?
Meiner Meinung nach krankt das Ganze sowieso an der großen Wahnsinnigkeit der Kühlschrankhersteller, die glauben, dass alles, was man irgendwie isst, in einem Kühlschrank gelagert wird. Und man vergisst dabei, dass zu einem Essen noch ganz viel andere Sachen gehören.
Naja, aber Gegenargumentation, sozusagen im Kühlschrank hast du das, was schnell schlecht wird. Das heißt, da sind die Kaufzeiten geringer, während du halt Nudeln kannst auch vier Kilo in deinem Kabuff legen.
Ja, aber der Lieferant kann dir vier Kilo Nudeln vor die Tür legen. Ein Steak, was den ganzen Tag vor der Tür auf dich wartet, ist vielleicht nicht mehr so geil. Also frische Sachen liefern ist nicht so einfach.
Warte, das Steak kommt nicht durch die Internetleitung direkt in den Kühlschrank rein? Und viel Spaß noch mit deiner Ordnung. Ich finde es wirklich spannend. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass noch mehr Leute von euch anrufen und auch erzählen, was sie für Erfahrungen gemacht haben mit dem Internet of Things oder mit Dingen, wo sie mal gesagt haben, okay, meine Daten darfst du haben. Ich will es mal bequem haben und wie die Erfahrungen für euch sind. Ich finde es wirklich spannend. So, und dann müssen wir noch über Puppen reden.
Ja, was die wenigsten Leute wissen, Hacker haben ein großes Herz für Puppen, vor allen Dingen dann, wenn in dieser Puppe einfach mal ein Computer verbaut ist. Und so auch hier passiert, nämlich Mattel hat jetzt eine Hello Barbie rausgebracht. Was unterscheidet die zu einer Hello Barbie von einer normalen Barbie?
Du wirst es mir sicherlich gleich verraten, Danimo.
In der Tat, die Hello Barbie, mit der kann man nämlich vordergründig als jemand, der mit ihr spielen will, reden. Die hat so einen Button und da kann man dann draufdrücken und dann kann man ihr was erzählen und die antwortet sogar. Also da ist halt so ein ähnlicher Algorithmus drin verbaut oder so eine ähnliche Funktionität drin verbaut, wie man sie auch bei Siri, Cortana, Google Now, wie sie alle heißen, ist. Jetzt könnte man sagen, naja gut, das ist das selbe Szenario, das wir eben beschrieben haben. Nämlich man überlässt Fremden die Sprachaufzeichnung, in dem Fall nicht nur von Erwachsenen, sondern sogar von Kindern. Aber es ist natürlich noch schlimmer, natürlich ist es noch schlimmer, in dem Fall ist es nämlich noch schlimmer, weil was passiert, wenn so ein Device jemand in die Hände kriegt, der gerne die Weißes aufmacht, er stellt fest, dass das ganz schnell ganz doll kaputt geht. In dem Fall war es eben so, dass sobald diese Barbie, die verbindet sich also übers WLAN mit dem Internet, um dann mit den Servern reden zu können, die dann die Sprache interpretieren und auch die Antwort liefern. Es scheint also so zu sein, dass, wenn man sich das mal genauer anguckt, dass man sehr einfach quasi die Eigentümerschaft über diesen Chip, der da verbaut ist, übernehmen kann und damit dann nicht nur Zugriff auf dieses Mikrofon im Kinderzimmer hat, was irgendwie schon schlimm genug ist, sondern dieses Gerät kann irgendwie auch noch die letzten Nachrichten, die das Kind mit seiner Puppe besprochen hat, abspeichern oder tut es sogar und auch das kann man dann im Nachhinein abrufen.
Das ist sogar ein Dienst für die Eltern. Also die Eltern können auf eine Webseite gehen, sich anhören, was das Kind mit der Puppe gesprochen hat und das auch noch mit anderen Eltern im Internet teilen.
Das ist die dritte Eskalationsstufe, weil ich das in der Tat noch schlimmer finde, wollte ich das jetzt auch noch erzählen. Das ist offensichtlich so im Helikoptereltern, Zeitalter Mode geworden, dass man auch wissen will, was die Kleinen so mit ihrer Puppe reden. Und das ist dann unter Umständen so süß, dass man das auch noch teilen möchte.
Oh, mich ist gerade ein bisschen schlecht geworden. Und das verkaufen die so offiziell als hier, das ist total toll. Und diese Puppe, ist das dann so auf Knopfdruck nimmt die auf oder nimmt die eigentlich immer auf?
Naja, sie nimmt, ich sag mal im Lieferumfang, sie nimmt im Lieferumfang nur auf Knopfdruck auf. Aber dieser Knopf ist einfach auch nur ein Software-Schalter. Und nichts, was jetzt jemanden, der auf diesem Gerät drauf ist, wirklich daran hindert, da einfach auch das Mikrofon auf Dauerlisten zu stellen. Und das einzige, woran es vielleicht auffällt, wie üblich ist, dass der Barbie schneller die Puste ausgeht im Sinne von Strom.
Wow, gab es eigentlich sozusagen einen Aufschrei, außer jetzt bei Leute wie euch, sage ich mal?
Es ging halt durch die Presse. Ich habe es hier inländisch tatsächlich nur in der IT-Presse verfolgt. Es scheint da nicht groß darüber hinausgeschwappt zu sein, wobei ich mir auch nicht sicher bin, ob es die Puppe schon für den deutschen Markt gibt, wo es definitiv große Wellen geschlagen hat, ist im englischsprachigen Raum. Aber ob das wirklich die breite Bevölkerung erreicht hat, kann ich nicht einschätzen.
So, das ist also auch Internet of Things. Gibt es noch mehr so Horrorgeschichten?
Ja, zum Smart Home gab es ja, die Telekom betreibt sowas ja auch. Denen ist halt neulich mal ihr zentraler Server ausgefallen. Und da war dann der Fall, dass die Leute, obwohl es anders versprochen wurde, ihre Lampen nicht mehr schalten konnten.
Also die Lampen haben dann nicht mehr funktioniert, also komplett nicht mehr.
Genau, also die Ansage war wohl, dass es halt auch ohne Internetanbindung geht, solange du dich zu Hause befindest. Dem war dann aber wohl zumindest beim Teil der Kunden dann doch nicht so. Und letztendlich, man muss halt auch immer daran denken, solange an so einer fernsteuerbaren Steckdose irgendwie deine Stehlampe hängt, ist das alles nicht so schlimm. Aber Menschen stecken halt in Steckdosen so ziemlich alles ein, was da rumsteht. Das kann halt auch mal die Herz-Lungen-Maschine der Oma sein oder dein Kühlschrank. Wenn du deinen Tiefkühlschrank, weil du warum auch immer auf die Idee gekommen bist, daran anschließt, dann hat die Cloud auf einmal Regen. Dein IoT-Device sagt, ich gehe mal in einen unklaren State und dann geht dein Kühlschrank aus, du kommst nach Hause, die Oma liegt in der Ecke und der Kühlschrank ist abgetaut.
Das sind jetzt so zwei Dinge, die möchte ich ungern miteinander vergleichen. Aber man sieht den Punkt, wo aufzunehmen wird. Es gibt doch außerdem auch immer mal wieder so Sicherheitsgeschichten. Das habe ich mich eh vorhin gefragt, als er einen der ersten Anrufer erzählt hat, irgendwie die Daten würden irgendwie unsicher übermittelt, die da alle anfallen. Das ist ja auch ganz spannend. Und es gab sich neulich irgendwie mit einem der Hersteller auch so ein Skandal? Der jetzt irgendwie gerade SIGB oder wie die hießen?
Ja, grundsätzlich hast du natürlich immer das Problem, diese Geräte müssen sich irgendwie miteinander unterhalten. Und das haben wir eingehends gesagt, man kann sowas halbwegs sicher implementieren oder auch nicht. In dem Fall dieser SIGB Geschichte geht es darum, also das sind auch so diese Philips Hue Lampen zum Beispiel, die sprechen ein, wie nennt sich's, Profil von SIGB. Ein Profil ist da immer so ein Subset von Featuren und das ist das...
Und SIGB ist ein Protokoll erst mal.
SIGB ist sowas wie WLAN und davon gibt es verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen.
Also es ist eine Art und Weise, wie diese Geräte übereinander sprechen.
Genau, es ist ein drahtloses Funkprotokoll oder eine Sammlung von Protokollen. Eine Geschmacksrichtung davon ist dieses SIGB Light Link, was der Name schon andeutet für Lichtsteuerung gedacht ist. Und das Problem, was du ja hast, also wenn du jetzt irgendwie mit deinem neuen Handy nach Hause kommst, dann gibst du deinen WLAN-Code da ein, dann ist das in deinem WLAN. Ein ähnliches Phänomen, du kommst mit deiner neuen Glühbirne nach Hause und die muss irgendwie mit deinem SIG B-Netz reden. Aber da du ja nicht willst, dass da jeder mitspielen kann, gibst du halt ein Passwort oder einen Schlüssel oder was auch immer. Aber wie gibst du dir diese Glühbirne ein? Die hat ja keine Tasten.
Stimmt.
Das heißt, du hast dieses Problem des initialen Provisionierens dieses Gerätes. Und in dem Fall war es so, ganz stumpf gesagt, dass es halt so einen Key gab, den die alle hatten, den darf halt keiner wissen, außer den Herstellern. Und damit können sie sich dann initial mit deiner Basisstation unterhalten, werden ins Netz integriert und alles ist gut. Solange niemand außer den Herstellern diese Schlüssel kennt und diese Schlüssel in die Lampen reintut.
Verstehe ich aber nicht. Wie kann das gehen?
Naja, stell dir einfach vor, es gibt ein geheimes Kotwort für die Gruppe, in der du sein möchtest. Du und deine zehn Freunde kennen das. Niemand versteht dich, solange er das nicht kennt. Und solange ist das auch total gut. Und wenn du neun in die Gruppe aufnehmen willst, dann sagst du ihm das geheime Kotwort und alles ist gut. Und wenn jetzt dein Freund eine Lampe ist, dann sagst du ihm das nicht, sondern das hat der Hersteller ihm dann schon gesagt. Und solange das kein anderer kennt, ist alles gut.
Ich verstehe es immer noch nicht. Wie kann denn eine Lampe wissen, wie das Passwort zu meinem WLAN ist?
In dem Fall ist es nicht dein WLAN, sondern dein SIGBI-PAN. Aber das Passwort kommt vom Hersteller. Das ist schon in deinem Router drin. Also das Ganze ist etwas komplexer. Man kann das jetzt nicht so in fünf Minuten erklären.
Warum nicht? Es gibt Geräte, die diesen Standard sprechen.
Die sagen es anders. Alle Lampen und alle Geräte haben vom Hersteller ein und denselben Key da reingebrannt. Und damit verschlüsseln sie die Kommunikation. Und solange niemand diesen Schlüssel kennt, der böse oft ist, der deine Lampen steuert.
Aber das heißt, das ist gar nicht... Das Problem kann durchaus sein, mein Nachbar hat solche Geräte, ich habe solche Geräte, dann kann es zu Verwirrung kommen.
Na, normalerweise nicht, wenn der Nachbar nicht böse ist, weil diese Lampen, da gibt es halt noch so Dinge, wie du musst es irgendwie an die Basisstation dranhalten. Aber wenn du diesen Schlüssel kennst, kannst du halt auch sagen, hallo, ich bin die Basisstation, sprich mit mir, auch wenn du gar nicht meine Lampe bist.
Also das Problem ist, normal, das Sicherheitskonzept lebt davon, dass in diesen Lampen alle derselbe Schlüssel verbaut ist quasi.
Also wenn ich diese Lampe kaufe, dann tue ich diese sozusagen dicht an eine Basis-Sendestation und durch die physikalische Nähe weißt du dann, okay, das ist das WLAN, mit dem ich reden soll.
Das ist das SIGBI, mit dem ich rede. Genau, das sogenannte PAN.
Da geht es wirklich über die physikalische Nähe. Und dann ist der Datenverkehr, der über die Luft stattfindet, verschlüsselt zwischen diesen beiden Punkten.
Genau, und für die initialen Kommunikationen haben sie von Werkau schon einen Schlüssel dabei. Darüber unterhalten sie sich. Und wenn sie das getan haben, rechnen sie sich einen neuen aus. Danach ist es alles nur noch hebso wild. Aber für diese initialen Kommunikationen haben sie alle den gleichen dabei.
Das heißt, wenn denen jemand redet, kann er jedem gerät, dass er per Funk erreichen kann, sagen, ich bin eine Basisstation.
Und statt zu erreichen, wenn überall dieser Schlüssel drinsteckt, dann kann man sich das Raten sparen und kann einfach versuchen, da dran zu kommen.
Aber du musst doch schon in der Nähe sein.
Man nimmt das Gerät auseinander und liest es aus und hat dann diesen Diffus.
Nein, das meine ich nicht. Mein Nachbar hat SIGBI-Geräte.
Dein Nachbar muss schon in deiner physikalischen Nähe sein.
Ja, genau, aber das reicht. Wenn die sozusagen in Funk-Reichweite sind und ich diesen Schlüssel kenne, weil ich den aus so einem Gerät rausgebastelt habe, dann kann ich mit dem reden und alles machen. Nein?
Ja.
Ja, gut.
So, und dieser Schlüssel ist rausgekommen. Das heißt, den weiß jetzt jeder.
Im Prinzip.
Ja, er ging über Twitter.
Stimmt, ich hab auch einen Tweet gesehen. Da kam so eine komische Zeit. Das heißt also, wenn ich diese Geräte zu Hause habe, dieses SIGBI, wie heißt das, Light-Lite-Protokoll sprechen, dann kann im Prinzip jetzt jeder, der technisch ein bisschen Ahnung hat, meine Zuhausegeräte bedienen.
Oder das Türschloss öffnen.
Wenn du Pech hast, sogar jeder, der keine Ahnung hat, wenn irgendjemand ein nettes Tool baut und es ins Internet stellt, dann musst du es in Zweifel nur noch runterladen.
Wie kann sowas, also kann sowas verhindert werden?
Ja, man macht sowas nicht. Man packt keine default-Keys in Geräte. Das ist halt eine Convenience-Abwendung. Die haben sich überlegt, wie kann ich das dem Endanwender möglichst einfach machen, die ausgepackte Glühbirne ans Laufen zu bringen. Haben sich dann für diese Lösung entschieden. Und ja, war keine gute Idee. Das ist halt, wenn du genug Aufwand treibst, kannst du aus einem Gerät immer die Geheimnisse entlocken. Ist halt die Frage.
Aber wie könnte man das anders machen?
Du könntest auf diese Glühbirne eine zufällige, wirklich zufällige Idee draufdrucken, die du diesem Router mitteilen musst, oder diesem Zigbee Gateway. Und dann kann er mit dem Ding reden. Sollte man aber auch nicht so machen wie die aktuellen WLAN-Router-Hersteller, die dann so eine Zufallszahler draufdrucken, die von der Mac-Adresse oder der Seriennummer abgeleitet ist. Die kann man dann auch wieder erraten.
Genau, die nicht zufällig ist.
Okay, also im Karton der Lampe läge ein Zettel drin, darauf steht ein Code.
Die will man schon so mit Laser auf das Gehäuse drucken.
Aber in dem Karton drin, so dass man es nicht von außen lesen kann, ist ein Code, den ich erst sehe. Wenn ich die Lampe raushole, den gebe ich ein.
Aber zusammenfassend ist wirklich das Problem, das die Hersteller haben. Es muss einfach sein. Es muss im Produktionsprozess gut machbar sein. Deswegen hatte man diese Durchzählbarkeit von Schlüsseln beim WLAN-Router. Und trotzdem muss es sicher sein. Und in diesem Spannungsfeld leben halt die Hersteller. Es muss einfach und sicher sein.
Ich frage mal andersrum. Wie sähe denn dein Internet of Things Gerät aus, das ihr euch installieren würdet? Was für Anforderungen müsste das erfüllen?
Es müsste in jedem Fall ohne externe Server, die nicht unter der eigenen Kontrolle sind, auskommen. Das kann ja immer noch eine Option sein. Wie der Kollege beim Fitbit eben sagte, vielleicht klicke ich auf den Knopf und sage, werte meine Daten noch besser aus und dann schicke ich sie raus. Aber ich sollte erstmal die Option haben, die Daten unter meiner Kontrolle zu haben. Am liebsten auch die Gegenstelle, womit das Gerät redet. Optimalerweise auf dem Gerät eine Firmware, die möglicherweise sogar Open Source ist, sodass ich reingucken kann und sehen kann, ach, das schickt meine Daten nicht nur an den einen Server, sondern auch noch an den anderen oder ähnliche Dinge.
Oder erfasst andere Daten, von denen ich gar nicht weiß, dass es die erfasst und schickt die noch mit raus. Also ich möchte schon maximale Kontrolle haben und so eine Wahlfreiheit. Möchte ich das lokal mit meinem Raspberry Pi, Banana Pi, was auch immer, oder dem Open-WRT-Router, der da rumsteht, auswerten und damit steuern? Oder gehe ich in den Convenience-Way und sage, es gibt da draußen verschiedene Dienstleister, die bieten mir das an, ich schicke meine Daten dahin und die werden das für mich außen steuern lassen.
Und das Requirement, das ich dazu fügen möchte, und das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich das Schwierigste ist, obwohl es das kann, muss es halt immer noch für Leute, also im Prinzip für jedermann bedienbar sein. Weil eine Sache, die irgendwie wahnsinnig toll für uns drei, vier hier im Studio funktionieren würde, würde halt die erste Serie nicht überleben, weil wenn es keiner sonst auf dieser Welt kauft, und das wäre halt sehr, sehr schade.
Gibt es das schon, was ihr jetzt beschrieben habt als Produkt?
Naja, zumindest in der Smart Home Welt ist es halt so, dass sich da eine ganze Menge Leute hingesetzt haben und quasi diesen zentralen Punkt ersetzt haben. Also dann nimmst du halt nicht die Steuerzentrale, die dir dein Hersteller dazu packt, sondern zum Beispiel einen Raspberry Pi oder was auch immer mit einem USB-Stick dran, der so ein Funk-Dings drin hat, was da mit deinen Heizungs-Sachen redet. Du kannst also schon die Produkte nehmen, also den Heizungsregler und den ganzen Kram, den du vielleicht sogar gerade von Wattenfall bekommen hast. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was die verteilen, aber es gibt eine ganze Menge Lösungen. Und dann tauschst du einfach die Zentrale aus. Das heißt, die Endgeräte benutzt du, aber das Ding, was wirklich mit dem Internet redet, das nimmst du ihm weg und stellst ein eigenes dahin. Und dann greifst du halt selber drauf zu.
Aber das ist dann so eine Bastellösung, also dann ist quasi lauter die A.
Naja, also mittlerweile ist es schon, ich glaube nicht, letztendlich, du startest halt ein kleines Programm und steckst einen USB-Stick rein. Also das ist schon auf dem Niveau angekommen, wo das eigentlich, sag mal so, wenn du das nicht hinkriegst, solltest du überlegen, ob du vielleicht von dem Internet of Things erst noch Abstand hältst.
Dann so weit erst mal dazu. Was ich von euch gern auch wissen würde, wenn ihr Lust habt, ist, was ihr euch vom Internet of Things wünscht. Also welche Art und Weise der Haus online anbringen würdet ihr euch wünschen. Wollt ihr zum Beispiel so einen Kühlschrank, der Essen bestellt, oder wollt ihr eure Lampen steuern, oder habt ihr noch eine ganz andere Idee? 0331 70 97 110 Ansonsten haben wir jetzt noch eine kleine Musik von Tears of God, Cross My Heart, Hope to Die. Danach gibt es die Nachrichten über Down Verkehr.
Und jetzt zu einer Band...
deren Konzerte eigentlich gar keine Konzerte sind. Sondern eher so ne Art Freakshow.
Und ihr seid die Hauptdarsteller.
Mittwoch, 10. Februar.
Deichkind live in der Max-Schweling-Halle.
Die Polizei hat ihre Razzien gegen mutmaßliche Islamisten in Berlin am Abend beendet. Es seien keine gefährlichen Gegenstände gefunden worden, sagte Polizeipräsident Kant im RBB-Fernsehen. Man habe zuvor einen ernst zu nehmenden Hinweis erhalten, dass entsprechende Aktionen in Berlin geplant seien. In Britze wurden zwei Verdächtige festgenommen. Einen zweiten Einsatz gab es am Nachmittag in einer Moschee in Charlottenburg. Es soll Hinweise gegeben haben, dass dort ein Anschlag geplant wurde. Auch Deutschland wird sich am Militäreinsatz gegen die Terror-Militie IS in Syrien beteiligen. Das hat die Bundesregierung beschlossen, um Frankreich im Anti-Terror-Kampf zu unterstützen. Demnach werden mehrere Aufklärungsflugzeuge der Bundeswehr bereitgestellt. Sie sollen Infos über Angriffsziele in Syrien liefern. Außerdem werden Tankflugzeuge und ein Kriegsschiff der Marine zum Einsatz kommen. Der Bundestag muss noch zustimmen. In Deutschland sind jetzt schon deutlich mehr Flüchtlinge angekommen, als von der Bundesregierung erwartet. Sie hatte bis zum Jahresende mit 800.000 Menschen gerechnet. Die Bundesländer sagen aber, dass es schon fast eine Million Flüchtlinge sind. Demnach kamen allein im November so viele Menschen an wie noch nie in einem Monat. Die Bundespolizei zielte bis Anfang der Woche mehr als 190.000 Einreisen. In Oranienburg sind vier Weltkriegsbomben auf einmal entdeckt worden. Sie sollen morgen Vormittag entschärft werden. Die Stadt teilte mit, dass die Bomben auf einem Grundstück im Ortsteil Lenitz gefunden wurden. Bis 8.30 Uhr morgen früh müssen die Anwohner im Umkreis von einem Kilometer ihre Häuser verlassen. Etwa 4.300 Menschen sind betroffen. In dem Sperrkreis liegt auch der S-Bahnhof Lenitz. Die Bahn will einen Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen einrichten. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, die liegen in Berlin-Tempelhof bei 2°C, in Küpenich sind es 4°C. Falkensee meldet minus 1°C, Prenzlau 1°C und Rangsdorf und Königsbusterhausen jeweils 3°C. Nachts sinken die Temperaturen um die 0°C, kriegen wir in Berlin und Brandenburg. Dazu kann es neblig sein. Morgen lockert es im Tagesverlauf auf und es soll überwiegend sonnig werden, bei maximal 4 bis 6°C. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100 stattdringt Richtung Neukölln. Die Überleitung zum Abzweig Steglitz ist wegen einer Baustelle bis morgen früh gesperrt. Aus Brandenburg haben wir keine Meldungen, aber dafür zwei von der Berliner S-Bahn. Und zwar auf der Linie S5 fahren zwischen Strausberg und Strausberg Nord bis Sonntag Busse Stadtbahn. Ebenso wie bei der S-Bahn Linie S25 zwischen Schönholz und Tegel. Da aber nur bis heute Betriebsschluss. Da wo es geht, reich eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, die letzte halbe Stunde steht an und wir reden heute hier im Internet über das Internet of Things mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club und das sind Mutag, Salon, guten Abend. Und der Peter. Hallo. Und wir haben in den ersten 90 Minuten, Gott, die Sendung ist eigentlich schon vorbei in meinem Kopf. In den ersten 90 Minuten gelernt, was Internet of Things ist und dass es halt noch nicht so weit ist, wie man sich das wünscht. Und das Hauptproblem, dass es damit gibt, ist, da werden Dinge in unserer Wohnung zum Beispiel installiert, die bequem über eine App zu bedienen sind, aber die sozusagen auch Daten an den Anbieter übertragen, was eigentlich gar nicht notwendig ist. Und die Sicherheitsbedingungen, wie die funktionieren, das ist alles noch so eine Sache.
Naja.
So. Zwei Themen wollen wir auf jeden Fall noch besprechen. Das eine ist politisch und das andere hat was mit Geld zu tun. Welches nehmen wir zuerst?
Geld?
Na, es geht noch um Versicherung.
Lassen wir damit anfangen.
Gut, fangen wir damit an. Versicherung. Was wollen die Versicherungen vom Internet of Things?
Ja, da gab es jetzt die ersten Versicherungen, die auf die schöne Idee gekommen sind. Wenn sie dir eine kleine Boxness-Auto einbauen, die deinen Fahrverhalten analysiert und du ordentlich fährst, wird deine Versicherung günstiger. Das Konzept kann man natürlich dann auch direkt sehr schön auf diese ganzen wie unser Fitbit übertragen, wenn ich eine Krankenversicherung abschließe. Habe ich jetzt so noch nicht gesehen, aber ist natürlich naheliegend.
Es gibt da auch schon so ein bisschen was am Horizont. Es gab jetzt schon Anfragen von Apple und Ähnlichem, ob sie nicht auf anonymisierte Daten, der Gesundheitsdatenkarten zugreifen und so. Total anonym.
Was will Apple? Will worauf zugreifen?
Na ja, wir haben ja jetzt auch demnächst ganz viele statistische Daten, die aus der Gesundheitskarte rausfallen, weil es ja alles direkt digital ist. Und es gibt jetzt wohl schon erste Anfragen von Anbietern, die so in diesem ganzen eHealth-Kram dabei unterwegs sind, ob man dann diese Daten nicht da vielleicht statistisch mal so auswerten könnte und so vielleicht so kopieren und so. Aber total anonym.
Was wollen die dann damit?
Na ja, ich denke mal, die Versicherung wollen halt ihre Statistiken ein bisschen updaten über Lebenserwartungen und ähnliches.
Ach so, ich habe gerade verstanden, die Apple will von den Krankenkassen. Nein, die Versicherungen wollen...
Na ja, es sind diverse Anbieter, die das wohl wollen. Unter anderem halt auch Apple, weil sie mit ihrem Fitbit natürlich einerseits Live-Daten haben von den Anwendern. Und wenn man das schön korreliert mit Gesundheitsdaten, kann man da vielleicht auch mehr rauskriegen. Keine Ahnung, also da ist einiges in Bewegung gerade.
Na ja, also bei den Versicherungen fand ich jetzt zumindest den interessanten Punkt, dass dein Verhalten dazu führt, dass du zum Beispiel mehr oder weniger Versicherungen zahlst. Das heißt, das funktioniert auch andersrum. Du wirst halt konditioniert. Das heißt auch andersrum, vielleicht sagt die Krankenkasse so, wir gucken mal.
Dein Schritt steht bei 5.000.
Du läufst nicht genug. Außerdem haben wir an deiner Armbewegung erkannt, du hebst öfter mal ein Bierglas mehr als du solltest. Wir stufen dich erst mal hoch oder wir versichern dich gar nicht erst. Oder vielleicht sagt auch, also diese Daten sind dann ja erst mal da. Vielleicht ist auch dein Arbeitgeber. Also ich habe jetzt mal bei Fitbit nachgeguckt. Also dich einzustellen ist mir eigentlich ein zu großes Risiko. Geh mal mehr joggen und komm dann wieder. Also die Daten sind halt erst mal da.
Und das das Schlimme ist, wenn du dich halt dafür entscheidest, da nicht mitmachen zu wollen, wird deine Versicherung halt teurer. Du kriegst die günstige Tarife nicht mehr.
Und das ist ja eigentlich egal, ob es teurer wird oder genauso teuer wie heute. Das Problem ist halt, was als das niveau als das akzeptable Niveau eingestuft wird. Und je mehr Leute da mitmachen, umso mehr wird halt gesagt, das akzeptable Niveau einer Versicherung liegt halt da, wo die meisten Leute abschließen. Und wenn viele Leute dann diesen Monitoring-Tarif, sag ich mal, wählen, dann ist das halt so eine Gruppendynamik.
Das heißt, man kann über kurzer Langzeit dazu gezwungen werden.
Zwingen klingt immer so, als ob da jemand mit einem Gewehr hinter steht. Das ist aber gar nicht mehr notwendigerweise. Das ist einfach ein gesellschaftlicher Effekt, der da eintritt.
Du hast schon die Wahl. Du musst noch ein bisschen weiter einen Weg zurücklegen. Also es ist halt aufwendiger, du musst mehr Geld dafür bezahlen. Oder länger suchen nach einer Versicherung, die das noch anmietet.
Das Spannende ist sozusagen, dass dann die Leute, die das Angebot annehmen, sich darüber im Klaren sein müssten, dass sie Verantwortung damit tragen, dass der gesellschaftliche Druck aufgebaut wird oder nicht.
Ja, aber tust du das? Ich glaube, die meisten Leute sagen, ich wollte eigentlich immer schon mal gesund leben.
Die Gegenfrage machen die Leute sich Gedanken, wenn sie ihre Kontaktdaten oder ihre Adressbücher bei Facebook hochladen, so komplett, mit allen Kontakten.
Naja, es ist nicht die Frage, ob sie es machen, sondern ob sie es sollten.
Naja, sollten sie nicht, weil die Leute sollen schon eigentlich selber entscheiden können, ob Facebook sie kennt oder nicht.
Vielleicht, um das mal wieder in den Alltag zurückzuholen. Es gibt ja, hat ja wahrscheinlich jeder dieses Kärtchen, von einem Zahnarzt einmal im Jahr reinschreibt, dass du beim Zahnarzt warst und dann ist dein Zahnersatz irgendwann belegert. Das ist bis jetzt so ein Papierstück, so ein Bonusheft. Und es gibt jetzt auch die ersten Zahnbürsten mit Bluetooth und Internet-Anbindung. Also warum sollte nicht irgendjemand auf die Idee kommen, genau wie dieses Heftchen jetzt, natürlich zwingt dich niemand dieses Heftchen zu benutzen. Und das ist ja auch ziemlich datenspar so. Da steht ja nur drin, dass du einmal im Jahr beim Zahnarzt warst. Aber warum sollte man das nicht einfach weiterführen und sagen, naja, wenn du dir nicht dreimal am Tag die Zähne putzt, dann wird dein Zahnarzt auch teurer. Und das ist dann vielleicht erstmal freiwillig. Und irgendwann ist das wie dieses Heftchen einfach der Default-Weg. Weil es hat ja jeder eine Bluetooth-Zahnbürste, warum auch nicht. Und dann wird es auf einmal so ein Problem eventuell. Weil dann bist du ja schon gezwungen, dich dieser ganzen Sache zu unterwerfen. Und bist auch gezwungen, so ein Gerät zu haben. Bist gezwungen, immer diese Hintenanbindung zu haben. Bist gezwungen, ja, also dein Verhalten wird fremdbestimmt durch Konditionierung. Weil du kriegst halt ein Zöckerchen, nämlich die billigeren Zähne oder was auch immer, wenn du mitspielst.
Und das Schlimme ist, wir werden die ersten, also die ersten Effekte werden wir sehen über diese Autoversicherungsnummer. Die wird nämlich zuerst kommen. Und da Deutsche und die Auto sehr verliebt ineinander sind und man da sicherlich gerne den ein oder anderen Cent spart, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das sogar sehr gut funktioniert.
Aber da kommen wir jetzt auch zur Politik, wo ich sowieso gleich wieder hin wollte. Weil Deutschland hat ja zur Zeit zumindest immer der Ruf zu sagen, sehr, sehr schwierig und streng zu sein, was den Datenschutz angeht. Und glaubt ihr wirklich, dass zugelassen wird, dass so eine Dinge installiert werden im Auto? Also weil ich habe schon häufiger mit Rechtsanwälten gesprochen und Datenschutz ist ja in Deutschland ein Grundrecht. Man kann Grundrechte nicht einfach so abtreten.
Na das Problem ist, das ist ja total freiwillig diese Box.
Also wenn ich hier mal gucke. Aber so geht es nicht. Sondern es gibt bestimmte Arten, die man, also man darf das nicht machen sozusagen. Selbst wenn man will. Also der Anbieter dürfte es quasi nicht anbieten.
Solange dieser Anbieter sich ans deutsche Datenschutzrecht hält bei der Speicherung deiner Daten, darf der das ruhig anbieten. Das heißt ja nicht, dass du ein Recht darauf hast, du kannst ja einfach nicht Auto fahren oder kein Auto besitzen. Aber der Datenschutz hilft in dem Fall, ja eigentlich nur deswegen, dass der Anbieter sie sicher speichern muss nach den Anforderungen, die das BSI da glaube ich gestellt hat. Das heißt aber nicht, dass er dir das nicht anbieten darf. Das heißt nur, dass er auf deine Daten aufpassen muss.
Google Now trackt ja auch komplett wo du bist und zeichnet das auf und macht da Bewegungsprofile. Sagt dir auch keiner was gegen? Also passiert ja. Hab ich bisher auch noch niemanden gehört, der sich da aufregt.
Spannend wird es dann nochmal, wenn Versicherungen dazu kommen. Da kenne ich mich rechtlich tatsächlich nicht so aus, ob es da noch mal spezielle Regulierungen gibt in Gesetzen, die jetzt das Versicherungswesen betreffen.
Ich vermute mal, so lange es einen Opt-out gibt, aber der halt mehr kostet, wird das wahrscheinlich irgendwie rechtend sein.
Wie ist es denn jetzt mit der Politik eigentlich und der ganzen Daten, die da anfällt, gibt es da? Wir haben da am Anfang bei IT-Gipfel gesagt, dass angeblich gesagt wurde, vielleicht müssen wir mal ein bisschen weniger Datenschutz und so. Wie war das genau?
Naja, das Problem ist, dass da, vermute ich, irgendwo ein Missverständnis da ist. Es gibt da eine ganze Menge Buzzwords. Eins ist zum Beispiel, dass wir jetzt ganz viel Big Data machen müssen. Und Big Data, das klingt ja so, als ob wir da unheimlich viele Daten verarbeiten müssen. Es ist alles groß und Big Data funktioniert nur, wenn wir ganz, ganz viele Daten haben. Und dann gibt es diesen Begriff der Datensparsamkeit. Das klingt so, als ob wir da ganz, ganz wenige Daten haben. Und für die Politik geht das nicht zusammen. Das führt dann dazu, dass bei dem IT-Gipfel der Herr Dobrindt auf der Bühne stand und meinte, diese Datensparsamkeit müssen wir mal ganz dringend überdenken. Die passt nicht mehr zu der Zeit. Das ist, also wir brauchen Innovation und Fortschritt. Dazu brauchen wir Big Data. Und zu Big Data, das geht nicht mit dieser Datensparsamkeit. Wir brauchen ja Daten. Und Frau Merkel trieb das dann noch auf die Formulierung, dass Daten, dass ich glaube, dass das Öl oder das Gold des nächsten Jahrtausends sind oder irgendwie sowas. Weil die alle nicht verstanden haben, dass Datensparsamkeit und irgendwie Innovation und Fortschritt und Big Data sich nicht unbedingt ausschließen. Es geht vor allem darum, was für Daten ich da erfasse und verarbeite. Und Beispiel Carsharing. Carsharing kann ich nur machen, wenn ich die Standortdaten der Autos habe und die mit meinem Handy in Verbindung bringen kann. Aber ich brauche zum Beispiel, wenn ich eine Google-Anfrage mache, für eine Standard-Anfrage nicht unbedingt den Aufenthaltsort, dessen, den der anfragt, wenn er nicht gerade nach Restaurants in der Nähe fragt. Und es gibt eine ganze Menge von Diensten, die mit weniger Datenspeicherung funktionieren würden und damit datensparsam wären. Es aber aus Bequemlichkeitsgründen nicht sind. Und da heißt es glaube ich durchaus, Naja, Missverständnis in der Politik da. Also von diesem Begriff Datenspeisamkeit.
Aber heißt das, dass wir uns jetzt davon verabschieden langsam? Weil Missverständnis ist ja nur der Herr, wenn die Politik das fordert.
Ich glaube nicht. In einem anderen Punkt habe ich zumindest am RT-Gefühl gemerkt, dass lustigerweise in der Wirtschaft einen Standortvorteil gesehen wird, wenn wir weiterhin beim Datenschutz und bei der Sicherheit vorne sind. Es gab dieses Panel, wie gesagt, mit unter anderem Herrn Demisier und Frank Rieger vom CCC, wo Frank gesagt hat, naja, vielleicht sollten wir in Deutschland einfach mal bei diesem ganzen Industrie 4.0, was nichts anderes ist als Internet of Things, auf die Industrie übertragen, wenn irgendwelche Roboterarme da miteinander reden. Vielleicht sollten wir da bei dieser ganzen Entwicklung so ein ganz, ganz kleines bisschen langsam auch vorwärts gehen, dafür aber vielleicht die Sicherheit von Anfang an einbauen und nicht versuchen, hinterher reinzufriemeln, weil das funktioniert eh nicht. Und da gab es von ihren Wirtschaftsvertretern im Saal Applaus. Made in Germany als Qualitätsmerkmal mit der Aussage, dieser Roboterarme kommt aus Deutschland, der durchschlägt nicht die Fabrikhalle und bringt Arbeiter um, weil da ist die Sicherheit von Anfang an drin eingebaut.
Naja, aber so irgendwie Roboter-Sicherheit und Datensparsamkeit sind noch mal…
Das ist ja ähnlich. Wenn man Datenschutz als Marke und Standort Vorteil etabliert hat, zu sagen, wir sind hier in einer Umgebung, wo wir auch so was Wert legen, zieht das durchaus so. Nicht umsonst haben Firmen wie Google und Ähnliches in Berlin das Headquarter, wo sie sich um Datenschutz kümmern, weil hier halt die strengsten Regulierungen dafür sind.
Naja, aber es ist schon die Frage, das haben die ja nur hier, weil sie das halt machen müssen, weil sie sonst irgendwie Ärger kriegen, und das momentan auch so ist. Und dieses Made in Germany war früher so ein Ingenieurskunststil, also die Sachen sind besonders robust, sie sind technisch besonders gut. Und das sind ja auch im Ausland, ist ja eine Qualität gewesen, die man halt gerne wollte. Während halt niemand irgendwo, also zumindest so gefühlt, jetzt danach nach Datenschutzprodukten fragt, also gibt es denn überhaupt einen Markt für, ist das nicht so Wunschdenken? Also einerseits von Menschen, die halt gerne datensparsam sein wollen, die denken, ja genau, guck mal Industrie, damit kannst du auch Geld verdienen. Andererseits von Industrie, die sozusagen immer dem innovativen US-Markt hinterherhängt und dann so hofft, okay, jetzt könnte man hier vielleicht damit noch, vielleicht wäre das ein Siegel. Aber ist es denn realistisch, dass man irgendwie so Made in Germany, Made with German Datenschutz als internationale Siegel etabliert? Ich halte das für ein bisschen naiv.
Naja, das spielt aber auch gleichzeitig noch in andere Sachen rein. Wenn du nicht die eine oder den einen Anbieter hast oder die eine Plattform, auf die deine Daten hochgeladen werden und du deine Daten lokaler speicherst, also jetzt mal mit dieser Home Automation als Beispiel, lässt dich natürlich auch auf industrielle Maßstäbe übertragen. Also wenn du quasi denjenigen, der diese Technik betreibt, in Kontrolle seiner Daten lässt, dann hast du auch viel eher die Möglichkeit, Interoperabilität herzustellen. Aber wollen die Leute das denn? Ja, da komme ich jetzt gerade drauf. Was wir gerade hatten bei Wattenfall, also was der Anrufer sagte ist, er ist jetzt im Prinzip darauf angewiesen, dass es Wattenfall ist. Das ist natürlich nicht unbedingt im Interesse des Stromanbieters, der ihm das jetzt zur Verfügung stellt, aber es ist im Interesse der Gerätehersteller, dass Leute einfach in der Lage sind quasi auch mal ihr Gerät zu kaufen und nicht immer bei der Stammmarke zu bleiben. Und es ist im Interesse von Konsumenten, weil sie sich nicht in so ein Wendolok in reinfahren. Also das schönste Beispiel, was wir da gerade aktuell in der Politik verfolgen, ist der Routerzwang, der jetzt aufgelöst wurde. Ich muss also jetzt nicht mehr den ranzigen Plastorouter, den mir mein Provider hinstellt, so akzeptieren, sondern ich darf jetzt auch wieder den Router meiner Wahl dort betreiben. Und wenn wir jetzt nicht zu weit abschweifen wollten, könnte ich Geschichten erzählen, die mehr als ein Ort der Mauer und das sowas halt sehr wichtig ist.
Aber das ist ja was anderes. Ein Anbieter stellt eine Internetdienstleistung zur Verfügung, dass sie an der Infrastruktur teilnehmen kann und sagt dann muss das Gerät dazukaufen. Bei Internet of Things ist es ja so, das Gerät ist die Dienstleistung.
Naja, das Heizungsthermostat und das Gateway für zu Hause ist halt so ein Gesamtprodukt und dann bist du auf den angewiesen. Aber das lustige ist, von wegen eigene Kontrolle und offene Systeme, wenn du die anguckst bei Twitter und Facebook, kannst du dir ein ZIP-Archiv runterladen mit allen deinen persönlichen Daten, weil sie in den USA dazu verpflichtet sind, dir als Konsument das anzubieten. Also da ist schon so eine gesetzliche Vorschrift, dass ich meine Daten da auch wieder wiederkriegen muss, komplett und unverändert, um sie woanders eventuell wieder einspeisen zu können.
Aber? Wiederkriegen von Daten ist halt schwierig. Du kriegst eine Kopie davon. Du kannst nicht sagen, gib sie mir, ich gehe damit zu jemand anderem und du hast sie jetzt nicht mehr. Das ist halt der entscheidende Unterschied.
Ja, da glaube ich nach wie vor, es gibt nicht wirklich eine Motivation oder sozusagen breites Interesse daran, dass Leute das wollen.
Ich denke auch, was da gesagt wurde, Standortvorteil, das kann man wahrscheinlich auch genauso gut andersrum fantasieren. Also es könnte sich da genauso gut jemand hinstellen, sagen so, wenn wir jetzt den Datenschutz komplett aufheben, dann können wir hier viel mehr Geld verdienen, weil unsere Wirtschaft würde hier aufblühen, weil wir viel mehr mit den Daten machen können.
Also das ist das, was halt diskutiert wird und das, was Dobrindt und Merkel von sich gegeben haben. Dass wir genau das tun müssen, damit wir weiterhin Marktführer werden.
Genau, deswegen ich bin nicht so optimistisch wie du, dass wir da jetzt argumentativ gewonnen haben und Deutschland jetzt Datenschutzland wird.
Das garantiert mich, aber es ist eine Chance. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit die beim Datenschutz gesehen und genommen wird von der Industrie, weil da gab es entgegengesetzte Äußerungen. Bei dem Security Aspekt, da scheint es zu funktionieren, was auch schon mal ganz schön ist, aber beim Datenschutz wäre es eigentlich auch ganz nett.
Also womit ich gerade daran denken muss, was ist eine Urbane mit so einem Thema, wo es Innovationen mal gab, die dann einfach so sagen, dass es versandelt. Und zwar hab ich neulich, wir sind ja relativ viel bei Google, fällt mir auf, aber es ist halt auch ein gutes Beispiel, Street View. Also dieses, ich guck mir an, wo ich bin. Das ist in Deutschland einmal gemacht worden und dann nie wieder aktualisiert worden, weil Google gesagt hat, das ist uns einfach zu aufwendig. Ich hab das halt neulich geguckt, also das Haus, wo ich wohne, das ist immer noch genauso verpixelt, wie es vor 5 oder 6 Jahren war.
Wird es auch bleiben.
Wird es auch bleiben, so dass es passiert. Also Google, also der US-Anbieter, der sich nicht um das anscheinend kümmert, sagt, das ist uns zu aufwendig, wir lassen das. Da ist aber niemand in die Bresche gesprungen, hat gesagt, dann machen wir so ein geiles Street View-Angebot. Das gibt es halt irgendwie nicht.
Na ja, weil jeder andere auch in dieselbe Problematik reinläuft. Also das ist ja keine Lex-Google-Level, sondern das betrifft jeden, der diese Daten nochmal erheben würde. Und du kannst nur hoffen an der Stelle, dass der Presse-Rummel über dein Street View nicht so groß ist, auf das weniger Leute Einspruch erheben.
Genau, dann könnte man sagen, das wird doch beim Internet of Things genauso sein. Es wird halt irgendwie international eine Entwicklung geben. Und in Deutschland werden wir halt weiterhin unsere Blühlampen mit der Hand anschalten.
Ja, wie gesagt, bis heute, also ich kann nur von mir ausgehen. Ich würde mir das halt nicht hinstellen. Aber ich sehe schon, wir sind da natürlich immer die Ausnahme.
Also ich würde es mir nicht hinstellen, wenn ich auf zentrale Serveranbiesungen bin. Aber ich denke auch, dass da gewisse Hersteller durchaus verstehen, dass du alleine wegen der Latenz und wegen der Infrastruktur, die sie selber vorhalten müssen, wenn sie mal viele Nutzer da drauf haben, das gar nicht wollen. Also wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass dieses Internet of Things richtig abhebt und ich habe dann da irgendwie 60, 80, 100.000 Benutzer, die alle ihre Glüben steuern und jedes Mal das über meine Server machen, skaliert das irgendwann so überhaupt nicht mehr. Und dann wird sowas kommen, wie das Apple TV oder das Google Ding, so ein kleiner Kasten, der zu Hause steht, der genau diese Dinge übernimmt.
Ich denke, diese Cloud-Anbindung oder Server-Anbindung ist ja auch nicht nur, weil die Leute Daten sammeln wollen. Wenn du jetzt, du möchtest ja dieses Feature haben, ich bin auch unterwegs und kann von unterwegs zu Hause etwas steuern. Und das ist heutzutage einfach nicht trivial möglich, wenn du nicht den externen Server benutzt. Weil die Leute haben halt diesen irgendeinen Router zu Hause, der hat für gewöhnlich irgendwie eine dynamische IP-Adresse. Und wenn du überhaupt noch eine Public-IP-Adresse kriegst, V6 ist noch nicht ausgerollt. Deine Glühlampe hat auf jeden Fall keine Public-Adresse zu Hause. Du müsstest von dem Kunden sehr viel technisches Know-how verlangen, damit es nicht über den externen Server geht, damit es direkt funktioniert. Also die Bastel-Lösung, von dem wir vorhin sprachen, kann natürlich auch eine große Firma bauen, aber es sind einfach technische Hürden, die heutzutage immer noch da sind. Wenn wir irgendwann mal den großen IPv6-Rollout haben und alles ein bisschen weiter ist, könnte ich mir auch gut vorstellen, dass ein paar der Anbieter genau das, was Mutags gerade sagt, überlegen, dass es jetzt so einfach für den Kunden ist. Ich kann dir ein Kistchen zu Hause hinstellen, ich muss gar nicht mehr für den Server betreiben, zahlt der Kunde den Strom, ist ja voll super. Man muss ja nicht mal das Schlimmste annehmen. Es gibt einfach auch handfeste Gründe, warum man diese Anbindung macht und die Daten woanders lagert. Genauso wie das Ding steht bei dir zu Hause, du kippst die Cola drüber, die Daten sind weg, der Kunde ist am heulen. Wenn es im Rechenzentrum ist, passiert es vielleicht nicht so schnell mit der Cola.
Auf der anderen Seite, die Gegensache, die sich dazu aufmachen lässt, ist, in dem Moment, wo jemand Geld ausgeben muss, um deine Daten zu hosten, und das sind ja laufende Kosten, die ich mir nicht über einmaliges Bezahlen dieses Gegenstandes, der da jetzt diese Daten sendet, refinanzieren kann. Das ist natürlich die Frage, wie finanziert er das Ganze, finanziert er das wirklich noch im Laufe des Verkaufs neuer Geräte, oder gibt er vielleicht auch noch Daten weg, um das zu refinanzieren? Wäre jetzt die Gegenthese dazu.
Puh, es bleibt also noch spannend, was Internet of Things angeht, und obwohl ich es nicht so offen lassen mag, glaube ich, kommen wir heute nicht zu einem besseren Schluss als diesem. Es ist noch viel zu tun. Was glaubt ihr, wann reden wir, wie viele Jahre werden vergehen, bevor es das Chaos-Radio gibt, weil es wirklich jeder hat? Tipp?
Fünf.
Ja, das halte ich schon sehr ehrlich.
Und, allerletzte Frage, werden wir jemals den Kühlschrank kriegen, der Essen bestellt oder wird das für immer ein Wunschtraum bleiben?
Ich denke, wir werden die Küche kriegen, die Essen bestellt.
Die ganze Küche gleich. Kocht die dann auch?
Nee, also es gibt mittlerweile schon so einen Prototypen von so einer Küchenzeile, die mit Roboter-Armen kocht. Aber ganz ehrlich, ein bisschen kochen will ich selber, ansonsten kann ich mir auch gleich die Pizza selber im Internet klicken.
Also ich finde Roboterkoch ganz sympathisch, will ich haben. Sehr schön. So, Chaosradio 218, das ist Instead of Things. Wir haben es angerissen und aufgemacht und müssen es jetzt so stehen lassen. Mal gucken, was dann auch passiert. Habt ihr noch Ankündigungen zu letztes Chaosradio im Monat? Da stehen ja manchmal Dinge an.
Sogar das letzte im Jahr.
Im Jahr, aber bestimmt im Monat sowieso im Jahr.
Ja, und statt des Chaosradios oder der Grund, warum es kein Chaosradio im Dezember gibt, ist der 23. Chaos Communication Congress.
Vielleicht auch der 32.
23. Der 32. natürlich. Und für den gibt es tatsächlich jetzt auch Tickets. Da haben viele Leute lange drauf gewartet. Und jetzt unter tickets.events.ccc.de zuhaben. Tickets für jenen Kongress im Hamburg, im Konferenzzentrum.
Vom 27.
Kauf, kauf, kauf. Warum sollen wir dahin kommen?
Weil es total klasse ist und weil neue Leute dort herzlich empfangen werden, unter anderem von den Chaos-Parten, die jeden erstmal, der es gerne wünscht, an die Hand nimmt und ihm zeigt, was es wundervolles gibt und wo er am besten seine Interessen ausleben kann.
Also falls ihr euch fragt, was ist denn eigentlich dieser komische CCC, dann könnt ihr euch das auf diesem Kongress sehr gut angucken, also wirklich die beste Antwort, die ich diese Frage geben kann. Und es gibt dort wie gesagt ein Projekt für Leute, die zum ersten Mal da sind, das sind die Chaos-Parten, wo Leute, die schon mal auf dem Kongress waren, mit euch zusammen über den Kongress ziehen und sagen, so hier guckt ihr diesen Vortrag an, bastelt an diesem Ding mit, macht dieses Schloss auf, dort ist das Bällebad. Solche Dinge, also falls wir uns dort sehen wollen, könnt ihr gerne auch dorthin kommen. Das war das Chaos-Radio 218, hier kommt jetzt Flo Heiler, bewirft euch mit Punk-Musik, ich verabschiede mich von Mutax. Dann Nemo.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Und der Peter. Schüsseln. Die Sendung erscheint als Podcast in dieser Nacht auf fritz.de, sehr bald dann auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich spreche Mikrofone und habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.